we have some major updates in the alec
baldwin case the cal rittenhouse case
man two big stories we just couldn't
figure out which one was more important
but we opted for the alec baldwin one
because
well the the case with cal right now is
going to be coming up the next week or
so we're gonna have a lot of time to
talk about that but we will talk about
both in the case of alec baldwin the
district attorney says that charges are
possible for alec baldwin and two
separate high-profile legal analysts
lawyers
have laid out the case as to why alec
baldwin may be facing at least
involuntary manslaughter charges now in
order to get anything higher than that
they'd have to find some kind of intent
and that's all they would need
seriously a prosecutor could find out
that she you know she once stole 20
bucks from his wallet and then he could
try and make the argument not a good
argument but right now they've
this this analysis from andrew branca is
actually really
poignant
that alec baldwin pointed a gun pulled
the trigger and had every opportunity to
inspect the weapon and did not do it
when and then you know i'll add he's
been trained over multiple decades
working in films knowing firearm safety
there were already negligent discharges
on set that crew had protested over so
you're really close to getting like
more than manslaughter but at the very
least that's what we could we could be
seeing now as for kyle rittenhouse this
is the kid in kenosha and i'm sure many
of you are familiar with this
things are looking pretty good at least
so far in a pre-trial hearing the judge
ruled that the men who lost their lives
cannot be called victims i guess the the
argument is the whole case is whether or
not kylo renos was justified in doing
what he did was it self-defense to refer
to these these men as victims basically
paints the picture that the answer is no
we know kyle killed these people the
question is was it warranted so the
judges outright said you can't call them
victims but you can call them looters
writers and arsonists and there's even a
point where the prosecution tried
arguing that this this man you know who
is who is shot
there's no evidence that he attacked
anyone else it's just arson and the
judge snaps and goes just arson come on
i can't believe what you're trying to
tell me
it was crazy to see the judge snap at
the prosecutor because well let's be
real the prosecutors don't have much to
go on you had riots going on for several
days and for weeks across the country
the police had said thank you to kyle
rittenhouse as he was showing up and
gave him water that's gonna be a tough
case but we'll see the jury could be
absolutely biased so we've got a bunch
of other news to talk about
joining us is charles lehman you want to
introduce yourself yeah tim thanks for
having me on my name's charles van
leeman i'm a fellow at the manhattan
institute tribute at city journal i work
on
[Music]
all things urban policy especially crime
uh which obviously is very relevant to
really both of these stories yeah this
would be great
and then we're also going to talk about
impeaching biden because before the show
he said the republicans are going to win
and they are going to impeach biden and
i really want to talk about that so
we'll do that we got luke as well yep so
the shirt i'm wearing right now first
appeared on the vlog and i saw it and
i'm like i love it i have to copy it and
it says i tested positive for freedom
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait hold
on hold on that was kent's idea for that
absolutely ken i got to send you a shirt
uh and maybe some royalties we'll talk
uh but i saw that we had a similar
version it said it said something almost
exactly the same but just a little bit
different uh and i was like this this is
too perfect i need to i need to copy it
and we we gotta we gotta make one
because in the vlog the other day kent
has you wearing a shirt that says step
on snack and fun find out i like that
one time like we gotta do that one as
well so kent we gotta talk and you can
get your shirt exclusively on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com
and you could also support me here at
the same time by doing so and we also
opened up mail yesterday which was
really fun i got a bunch of cool stuff
like this polish solidarity sign and a
garbage pail kids luke puke
card which is really freaking awesome so
i got a bunch of stuff i got a lot of
stuff to hang up on the wall so really
how do you say solidarity in polish
like like like the guy that was going
through the soviet government yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay that was a
great he patted me on the head when i
was a little baby wow so yeah that was
the name of the big movement in poland
yes the the kind of union of people
coming together saying uh we really
don't like communism we like to eat and
we prefer food over uh stamps but they
said we don't like communists or nazis
exactly like it's all bad exactly so the
polish have a long history of resisting
left-wing and right-wing tyranny uh and
i'm very proud of my heritage and my
people and my grand great grandparents
paid the ultimate price fighting all of
those crazy ideologies and i want to
make sure we don't have to fight them
here right on you know i also received
that was actually really beautiful
um this amazing coin from 600 a.d
they're about emperor fox from the
byzantine emperor so cool byzantine
empire i mean this person understands my
obsession with ancient artifacts so
thank you and i really want to give a
shout out to bnb forge and leather
company who forged this by hand it's a
knife look at this thing
this is a cutting knife that i'm going
to be using my cooking shows in the
future probably for years to come it is
incredible you guys this guy forged it
by hand and sent me the document of the
process so thank you so much that's so
neat and check out the cass castle vlog
if you want to see us opening this stuff
i think it'll be live tomorrow this
episode that was actually super fun we
went downstairs last night after the
show and we opened a bunch of those
things it was a lot of fun it was very
much like christmas i really appreciate
all of you guys for sending us stuff i'm
excited for this evening too let's get
going before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member and you'll
get access to all those fancy tim cast
members only segments we actually have a
couple let me let me just let me just
pop over here to the members area we got
tim cast live hangout with ryan long and
danny polish
so if you want to see an extended
version of the vlog that's got all of
this stuff from us partying at the event
and having a good time and we got some
of the jokes from ryan long and they're
particularly offensive you'll enjoy that
go to timcast.com become a member and
we're gonna have a member segment coming
up we will we release it around 11 p.m
every night but don't forget to like
this video right now hit smash that like
button don't just hit it smash it
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends just take the url
right now and paste it everywhere you
can it really helps out
and uh let's let's get into this first
big story we got this from the new york
times criminal charge is possible in
shooting on alec baldwin's set d.a says
an inquiry into how a cinematographer
was killed with a gun the actor was
rehearsing with which was not supposed
to have live rounds in it could take
weeks
they said the santa fe county district
attorney said on tuesday that she was
not ruling out criminal charges in last
week's fatal shooting on a film set alec
baldwin was rehearsing with a gun that
he had been told did not contain live
ammo when it went off killing the film
cinematographer so we know this now i've
got i've got a few questions first let
me just read this quote
d.a mary carmack altwy says we haven't
ruled out anything everything at this
point including criminal charges is on
the table
i just i just want to point out the
entire time the story has been in the
news cycle alec baldwin has been given
every benefit of the doubt and it's been
wrong every time the first they said was
it was a blank and it was a misfire
now then we learn from the union it
wasn't a blank but it was a misfire now
we're learning alec baldwin pulled the
trigger it wasn't a misfire
i i i you know i i think that's even
interesting too
was it negligent discharge or was it
alec baldwin intentionally discharging
the weapon that's why this starts to get
into criminal territory
and there's also a lot of people
complaining about the production cutting
corners a lot of staff saying that they
were terrified because the guns were
going off beforehand incorrectly uh and
and hearing you know misfire by the
mainstream media it doesn't tell the
story here at all so we're seeing a
concerted effort to try to murky the
waters already so at least at least
there should be an investigation here to
find out what really happened misfire
specifically means the gun didn't go off
so that's incredible negligence by the
media saying that twice yeah they were
obsessing about it it's like fully
semi-automatic yeah they don't we're
talking about
whether he intended to or not it was a
negligent discharge and i think it i
mean there were three people that i can
tell her involved hannah gutierrez reid
is the armor who handed the weapon to
dave halls who was the assistant
director who handed the gun to alec and
told him it was cold
well this is according to this story
from latimes.com what i'm saying you
know i hear you yeah what i'm saying is
we've been told every step of the way
one thing and that only to find out
later that wasn't true
so one of one of the details that i read
was that there were three different guns
and someone walked over and grabbed one
so i i kind of feel like him claiming he
told alec it was cold it's just them
covering you know their asses
i think this is from the director's
testimony
they got a hold of the director and
they're like what happened he's like
dude i mean it's gruesome
you really want to hear about what
happened he the girl was paralyzed by
the bullet first couldn't feel her legs
and then she died it's absolutely
horrible
negligent i mean you want to
this is
you know
for someone who lectures about how
dangerous firearms are he sure didn't
take this matter seriously
uh well so i i i kind of feel like
manslaughter is possible but you know
when i was bringing this up earlier
charles you were just like never going
to happen no i i well i mean you know
the
look the the the calculus is ultimately
political it's like does the santa fe
prosecutor what what what are her
aspirations and does she want uh a media
trial just gonna have to navigate in the
media trials suspect the answer is no a
i don't think i don't think the trial
happens that he would uh be convicted i
think the jurors can convict i think
he's too sympathetic and b
uh i don't think there's any interest in
actually going out and prosecuting the
case yeah yeah just from political
perspective you know i i don't know what
happened i don't think you know what
happened i think we can guess but but i
think it is it is unlikely nobody wants
that heat nobody wants the attention of
a celebrity murder case i think i think
most people hate him and you know people
like alec baldwin
he's kind of a jerk people like al
baldwin not half the country does and
that's and that's the big issue when it
comes to issues like kyle rittenhouse
derek chovin we know antifa will go
around and smash up windows and burn
down buildings and the right won't do
anything like that so there's already an
obvious you know it's it's a it flows in
one direction the prosecutor's gonna
look at this and be like okay let's say
we do go after alec baldwin we're gonna
get a bunch of crazed you know lefty
types screaming in our faces yelling at
us
and let's say we don't prosecute him
nothing happens yep okay so which do we
choose i think lady justice is blind and
if an actor negligently discharges a
weapon that he should have inspected and
kills someone that a a manslaughter
charge is warranted
well
let me read this from legal insurrection
this is where it gets interesting
because the dea is saying they could
have criminal charges and andrew bronco
we've had on the show before yes he's
got excellent analysis on the written
house case which we you know and we'll
talk about that case in a second
they say alec baldwin situation
beginning to look a lot like
manslaughter the more we learn about the
fact the case within the context of new
mexico criminal law the more this
shooting looks increasingly like a crime
specifically felony involuntary
manslaughter
he goes on to say the relevant facts
assumed to be established one that it
was alec baldwin who was manipulating
the gun that fired the projectile that
killed miss hutchins two that the gun
discharged because the trigger was
depressed by baldwin and not because of
some defect in the weapon
three the muzzle of the weapon was
directed towards miss hutchins by
baldwin when it was fired eg she was not
killed by an unpredictable ricochet
four the gun contained a live round the
bullet of which struck and killed miss
hutchins
five the ball that baldwin had the
opportunity to inspect the weapon of lot
for live ammo before he directed it at
miss hutchins and pressed the trigger
killing her and lastly
there was no justification for the
shooting of miss hutchins
now interestingly
some of these
recently our new developments such as
that he pulled the trigger that he
pointed at the woman and then he pulled
the trigger
initially people were saying misfire as
if to claim that like i heard one report
they were like oh someone pulled the
hammer back and handed it to him and
then when he was holding it it just went
off like is that that's what misfire
meant no misfire means it didn't shoot
this was negligent discharge the other
the other relevant factors which i which
i've stated but for the context right
now i'll say again
there's a witness who uh not a witness
but i guess you could say a character
witness someone who's worked with
baldwin who says that they worked with
him in the past and he was always very
careful that was back in i think the 80s
or something that means alec baldwin has
decades of firearms training on set he's
a producer of the film there were
already neglig negligent discharges on
the set that crew had complained about
so you can't say he didn't know
then he was handed a weapon aimed at the
woman and pulled the trigger that sounds
like i mean
from
from a legal perspective you're not a
strong parent of legality but but for me
from a firearm safety perspective the
number one rule of even a prop gun is
that you don't point it at somebody
unless you're willing to pull the
trigger and uh as as you were saying
somebody who's so
uh aware of how dangerous firearms could
be this is it's like there was no reason
to put a prop gun at somebody who's
you're not actively using i don't know
if he's aware if he was aware i think
this would have been prevented he sure
preaches a lot a lot of this political
ideology against people who uh want to
have the right to defend themselves the
the the first rule of firearm handling
you know every every time uh one of one
of my foreign colleagues i got named
steven katowski who now runs he runs a
gun news site called the reload um but
he's one of the one of the best firearm
reporters in america right now and
steven uh took a bunch of his shooting
at the nra range which is a good time um
and and and the first thing that they
tell you everybody in that room is
viscerally aware of the importance of
triggering this plan of being women's
safety's on when the safety's off where
you're pointing your gun only ever
pointing the gun downrange if it's if
it's loaded only ever pointed down like
these are you know if you're if you
genuinely will there's a deadly weapon
or you believe it's a facsimile of a
deadly weapon you have to treat it as
such because always be loaded
let's think about the absurdity of the
argument i keep hearing from people
defending alec baldwin just it's it's
the most insane thing ever i'm getting
all these tweets they're like clearly
tim has never been on set before and
they're saying things like tell me
you've never been on a movie set without
actually telling me about a movie set i
just want you to imagine that you're on
a movie set
and i've been on sets before i've been
on sets of tv shows and films and i just
want you to imagine you're working
you're a pa or whatever you're you got
you know look at the warner brothers
water tower and then all of a sudden you
see alec baldwin pull out a gun and
point it at you and you're gonna be like
this is totally fine it's hollywood
people point guns at everybody all the
time
there's nothing weird about this at all
no if if if that actually happened
people would be screaming and running
yet for some reason here
alec baldwin drew a gun pointed it shot
killed somebody
and they're acting like it's normal it's
not normal no what it looks like they
were in the middle of a shot
the crazy word shot
uh they're in the middle of this this
take and they they got bad light so they
had to move the camera and it's like
momentary lapse of thought i i think
that all three of these people hannah
gutierrez reid dave halls and alec
baldwin are all culpable for this
killing alex responsible all three of
them are
deserved to be investigated in charge
for this the the the the woman who was
the armorer
she made a mistake but she didn't point
a weapon at somebody she handed someone
a loaded gun so what so that's illegal
she didn't well she handed a a a
actually i don't think she even had to
go up into somebody it was the assistant
director who picked the gun up and
handed it to baldwin okay so
she's got guns
and and someone comes up and grabs one
i don't think necessarily that that
that's that's that's criminal it's her
job to have the weapons on set according
to the story they went to lunch and then
they came back and they just gave so
someone while they were away at lunch
the guns were unattended yep that's
that's the armorer's fault
yeah but i don't know if that's
like are you implying that while they're
away someone's snuck in and put a live
boat it's possible you know
but in that case the person who put the
bullet in there is at fault definitely
well there's that's like there's reports
that some of the staff were using the
the gun for
just target practice even before that
with live ammunition so i mean this goes
along with the kind of narrative that
we've been hearing that they've been
cutting corners that they were just
trying to make sure that they produced
this movie as cheap as possible the
staff were protesting they were mad they
walked off set for safety concerns
before this incident they walked offset
because of conditions that they said
weren't right on this movie set but alec
baldwin and the production staff still
continued and uh i mean this is where we
are right now we have a story from fox
news i say mark how do you pronounce
that gary ghost famed lawyer says he'd
be shocked if involuntary manslaughter
not brought in baldwin rust shooting i
gotta be honest i i agree with you i'd
be shocked if there are charges brought
this is a guy who is an establishment
activist you know she's really well
loved though
and he has a lot of money in the legal
system here in the united states it
doesn't matter if you're right and wrong
it matters how much money you have it
matters what kind of lawyers you could
hire and he's going to hire
if there is charges he's going to hire
the best lawyers that they are that will
give him the best justice that he could
afford and he could afford a lot of it
so let's just be honest how the legal
system works here because a lot of times
it doesn't matter what happened a lot of
times it matters who you got on your
side and how much money so you think
he'll throw the blame on dave halls who
handed him the gun and said it was
unloaded i think there's many avenues
here i don't know uh but there's many
different avenues that i see that i'm
running with potentially here
i think uh
i think there's gonna no one's gonna get
in trouble for anything they're gonna
say it was an accident oh we're so sorry
he's gonna make a donation and it'll all
just go away i'm not obsessed with
punishment i i definitely think that
throwing someone in jail isn't
necessarily the best way to make sure
they don't commit a crime again but i
definitely think this looks like a
manslaughter i agree like what would
jailing alec baldwin do to prevent him
from doing this again
i kind of feel like he won't do this
again you know
but people want some kind of emotional
satisfaction well i mean it's not just
emotional satisfaction right the the
justice system shows a variety of
functions but retribution is not just
about emotional satisfaction with the
public it's about the fact that there
was a real harm done regardless of
intent and there has to be some response
to that the absence of the response is
harmful i'm trying to i'm trying to
figure out yeah i'm trying to forget
over here what the deal is with the
district attorney who's you know going
to be
uh this attorney's offices are highly
politicized today in 2021 where they
were five ten years ago um it's she
seems like uh
she seems like a a career professional
but you know
she has an enormous amount of power in
making these decisions it turns on it
turns on her
uh essentially unlimited discretion
whether or not to break charges you know
actually you bring that up it's actually
really simple
is she a democrat or republican i she's
i i didn't look it up uh but she's santa
fe district attorney she's a democrat
she's elected then he's not going
anywhere yeah but what you sounds like
maybe you're implying that if nothing
happens if no charges come that actors
in the future won't really care if they
happen to also issue a negligent
discharge oh no i think they will i mean
i think
deterrence matters as well for
punishment right but like in this case
it's not about deterring alec bald it's
not about deterring other people like
alec bald's probably not gonna like go
out and shoot a bunch of people but it
is about like the the primary function
just system in this case is adjudicating
to what extent the person was harmed was
harmed uh in a way that violated the law
and then if that's true how they can uh
get reciprocity for that harm yeah well
a civil suit's coming and alex going to
be paying out millions to the family
regardless of criminal culpability alec
baldwin is responsible and it's
remarkable how many stands for baldwin
can't accept that i'm a big fan of his
work in 30 rock you know jack donaghy is
one of the funniest characters in a tv
show 30 rock's amazing you know and uh
he's in beetlejuice great good for him
he's kind of a bad person but i didn't
separate the art from the person
but you know let's let's talk about the
invert the inverted story now we got
this with uh kyle rittenhouse this one
actually really surprises me this is
from npr
prosecutors cannot call those shot by
kyle written house victims a judge has
ruled and he also ruled
they can call them arsonists riders and
looters
i didn't see this coming there's been a
few rulings in favor of kyle
writtenhouse in these pre-trial hearings
the trial i believe is what six days
november first it's supposed to start
november first any day now oh man jury
selection is coming up
i was saying before that i thought kyle
rittenhouse was going to get life in
prison right because the jury was is
going to be unwilling to go up against
the riots when those riots happened in
kenosha the only people who came out and
did anything
was for the most part written house and
the people with him the militia guys the
cops said thank you for being here and
gave them water
but do you think the jurors are happy
about that i'm sure they're just like i
wish there was no conflict now if they
side with rittenhouse and those
individuals maybe they can cross their
fingers that those people will come out
and defend their neighborhood after the
riots happen or they can say you know
just he's guilty and he can go to jail
and then we don't have to worry about
riots at all this is going to be a very
important case because a lot of people
are betting on this case a lot of people
uh you know there's a lot of
implications for betting like in vegas
uh a lot of people are doubling down and
investing in this and a lot of people
are threatening to riot a lot of people
are threatening a lot of civil
disobedience a lot of people are
threatening to do violence to others if
this court decision doesn't go the way
that they want it to go so so you see
this politicized in in so many different
ways and that's why it's going it's
going to be so difficult to actually get
true justice here i believe uh because
of how many people from the outside are
involved in this how many people are
investing into this and what i mean by
betting i mean uh putting political
capital into this because a lot of this
hangs in the balance of where this cur
where this country is going to go that's
how a lot of people see it and if they
see if kyle wins this is going to be a
plus for the right wingers if kyle loses
this is going to be good for the left
wingers and these are big sides that are
mounting a lot of power behind this
major court decision i think it's i
think that it's right he's a totem and i
mean i don't have a strong opinion on
the on the case i mean that's why we
have that's why we have an adversarial
criminal justice system i i the jury
should know more about it than i do um
but i do think you know the the context
of the case
uh this sort of like mass
temporary collapse of civil society that
happened last summer is the context in
which this all became possible the
context which like a a teenager just
viably or not was out patrolling the
street yeah weapon
like like something deeper has gone
wrong
that you get to that point regardless of
whether or not he was justified in the
individual shot where he said you said
temporary collapse
they aren't they aren't currently okay
they're not they're not doing great in
minneapolis but they aren't currently
having exactly in kenosha they're having
exactly the same level of writing that
they were having i i think this is a
symptom of the greater problem which is
the collapse of civil society if you
take a look at the federal level
politics if you take a look at even
state state politics
it just it right now it just feels like
the law is
if
you are in line with the party in power
you're good if you're not you're out
democrats control most of the cultural
institutions basically all of them right
now they have congress and the executive
branch
and as much as conservatives might you
know people might claim the
conservatives have the supreme court
it's still kind of an establishment
conservative based on the supreme court
not a populist trump supporting one so
what happens well alec baldwin likely
will
you know face no charges cal rittenhouse
is facing very serious homicide charges
the crazy thing is there's a lot of
people that want to say right now as a
hero and i don't think we need to say
that i think the situation was bad all
around and people shouldn't have been
there but it's it's it's it's hard to to
to discern exactly you know
how it should have went down i'm not
going to have all the answers but when
you have someone like destiny who is the
leftist streamer
getting he got banned from twitch's
partner program for saying definitively
this was the clearest case of
self-defense he'd ever seen or something
that effect
like the fact that they charged him with
homicide in his very serious charges
says to me they're expecting to fail
so my my favorite example is did you
follow the case of the uh of the two
new york uh highly educated lawyers who
got picked up uh confirmation the
conflict
yeah the guy the the the two people who
went out and like three miles have
cocktails and cop cars um
and what i what i love about that story
is the rallying to their defense like if
you go look at if you look at federal
records uh there were lots of people
that got picked up for arson charges
like uh guys who threw multiple
cocktails at the courthouse in seattle
uh people who bring their cop cars and
yet peculiarly these are the ones who
like got a full court press in the media
these these two highly educated
well-connected activist lawyers who
decided they would go out joy riding
with you know explosives and attack a
cop car
um handing them out were they giving
them out to people yeah uh and then well
they and they and they received and they
received like
adulatory attention and all of the kind
of the the reason is because they know
the people who know the people who write
the coverage they are in the position of
power and so
they they eventually they they pled
guilty they're going to go to sentencing
i think they're not the statute of
action is 10 years it's not going to get
10 years they're not getting it nobody's
saturated there's major media
organizations running defense for them
yeah um i mean i mean this goes along
with what was happening last summer i
mean dozens of people were murdered
people were burned alive and then we had
people like kamala harris raising money
for them to get them bailed out of jail
right so that tells you that they found
in the minneapolis in the minneapolis
riots it was what like a month after a
building had burnt to the ground they
found a corpse yeah they didn't even
know he's the missing person they're
like oh the writers
yeah yeah the writers killed them the
murderers and
and you know it's it's what's what's
important about this is is not just the
like the the writing the writing happens
it's the normalization the cultural
normalization of writing and
simultaneously the approbation for law
enforcement because you know those were
simultaneous phenomena is like there was
there was a collective the real problem
we were being told as our cities were
burning was that the cops are too tough
would that be considered murder if you
if you burned a building down and
there's a person inside that you didn't
know he's in there of course but at the
same time a lot of people were unhappy
with the cops even on the even on the
right because of the lockdowns cops are
coming along shutting down small
mom-and-pop businesses people on the
right were like wait wait wait what is
this back to blue flag that i have here
that absolutely is is hypocritical for
me to have if i actually believe in
personal freedom and liberty i was i was
i was told coming in that i was gonna
have to be the one defending the cops
[Laughter]
yeah i mean you know i think i think i
think
look the responsibility the iran
maybe you don't want to eliminate that
particular topic now but but in general
it's not so the police is preserved
civil order and of course the law is
written yeah and you know allow walmart
and costco to be open while they shut
down the small mom-and-pop businesses
yeah would you say that's ethical and
right and moral no i would not say
that's ethical or writing immoral i
would also say that the problem is not
with is not with policing as an
institution
well i think i think policing just in
general obeying orders from bureaucrats
when they're immoral illegal and decrees
is is a huge moral problem in this
country and why a lot of people on the
right didn't support them when black
lives matter stepped onto the streets
and were saying hey we don't like these
cops a lot of right-wingers secretly
they were like yeah yeah they got a
point i don't like them either because
of what they just did to me same
attitude of
uh
concern or or
opposition to civil society it's like
look at the end of the day we live in
society there's rules you don't have to
like the real estate process for
changing these rules i think there's a
problem that this process has become
increasingly abstracted from uh
democratic accountability that's bad but
like at the end of the day if you like
the rules you still have to follow them
if you don't we don't decide anymore if
you actually we can't we can't decide
where no
we can't live in society where uh you
can be free to throw a molotov cocktail
of people and get free free defense in
the press and while i agree
that uh unequal fortune is bad and bad
rules are bad like the the ground trust
in that loan order i think is is
critical for running a stable
functioning policy and you're right
except when it comes to luke's examples
the police were shutting down businesses
by decree without legislative process so
these were cops who were saying look
it's not a law it's not democratic it's
not legal but the guy who signs my
checks told me to do it so i'm going to
do it anyway and they did it selectively
so the politicians friends got to do
whatever they wanted to billionaire take
a look at de blasio painting black lives
matter in the street and then sending 27
cops to defend that that was an illegal
seizure of taxpayer dollars to do or or
uh sure sure you know i think i think
hypocrisy on the part of executives is a
major problem throughout the pandemic if
it's if it's gavin newsom dining at um
uh the french restaurant the laundry
right
french laundry
if it's uh all the big city mayors who
have been caught not wearing masks or
they continue to impose mass mandates in
their cities it's a major pro uh
uh like bite administration officials
keep getting picked up not wearing masks
in public um on the amtrak
lori
and nancy pelosi getting their hair dude
yeah and and
there was a uh an incident in north
jersey where when they shut down all the
businesses a woman was doing a facebook
live stream showing off the things she
sold and cops came to her business and
said ma'am you need to close and she
goes what are you talking about we are
closed and they're like no turn your
phone off
that's the crazy thing there was no law
saying you couldn't post a video online
and say hey i got stuff you want to buy
it and the cops came and threatened her
who are these cops
these are the people so so this is the
problem i have
if this is the direction placing is
going where cops are quitting over
vaccine mandates they're refusing to
abide by the edicts and those who will
abide by the edict are staying in place
then we don't have what you described
police officers keeping civil society
you know functioning and enforcing the
rules
what we have are people who are not
enforcing the rules who are just acting
as lackeys for despots who are ruling by
decree in which case we need to stop
that now if abolishing the police is too
extreme and maybe it is then we need to
fire all the cops that are unwilling to
abide by the law and then hire cops who
are and how we do that maybe it's a
review process then but all of these
cops that are remaining right now need
to be questioned it's like hey we have
you on video shutting down a small
business by decree
we're firing you because of that or we
have a video of you beating a black man
in the street for no reason yeah you're
getting fired over that yeah so but i so
i think that's right you wanna you wanna
fire the guy who beats black me on the
street for no reason every cop that i
have talked to
says independent of the like merits of
the case like derek chevron was not the
guy that they want to be he's not they
they were not fans of his every cop that
i've spoken to um like he was he was he
he was doing something wrong um but i
think i think
policing in particular is so subject to
this like very particular um
uh critical lens where we like pick out
the most high salience harms uh do i
think that you know you you can go back
and forth about like the the validity of
public health edicts or their like the
the arbitrary way in which they were
enforced although i was gonna be forced
arbitrarily a little bit i think there
are lots of abuses but i don't think
that what i'm interested in defending is
like the institution of policing as such
because that's the thing that i think is
under attack i kind of disagree with you
because you know people throughout
history you know always argue we need to
do the legal thing well it was illegal
to segregate people based on their race
it was legal to put people in
extermination camps it was legal to do
all horrible atrocities that governments
have committed throughout human history
and it was written decree by the law by
executives by by you know whatever
processes and i think some of those have
to be questioned sometimes the law the
law right absolutely laws the law is the
least worst governance that we have
right it's it's it's just it's it's not
good it's just better than the absence
thereof um i would
maybe i would i would argue that there
would be less harm i think as we were
discussing to bring the conversation
full circle the the thing that gave
birth to written house is what anarchy
looks like i think that that is
absolutely not that's a narco tyranny no
no no if it wasn't for the state
incentivizing putting fuel on that fire
making that fire that much worse working
hand in hand with the mainstream media
showing that george floyd footage over
and over again enraging people we would
have never happened if we didn't have so
many state elements participating cops
were there they were for that for for
days these people were burning down
buildings there's a video where a guy in
his 70s was his his mattress store i
think it was was being burned down and
when he tried stopping people someone
went behind him and cracked him over
this over the head with a rock left him
lying on the ground unconscious and
bleeding out and the police stood back
and did
nothing so why why am i going to support
these guys why am i going to pay for
these guys when kyle rittenhouse and his
crew showed up the cops said thank you
for being here and gave them water so
just one last point when it finally
reaches the point where they were
pushing a flaming dumpster towards a gas
station and they were we have video
footage and we've had three different we
have four no we've had five witnesses so
many on this show telling us that's what
they were doing and the police did
nothing what do we do we can sit back
and say there was a good possibility the
gas station could have blown up
or kyle rittenhouse took a fire
extinguisher and put the fire out to the
trot they chased after him and then
someone fired around either into the air
or at him depending on who you ask the
press says in the air new york times
says that some witnesses we've spoken to
said it was at him and then he turned
and was attacked by rosenbaum and fired
in self-defense if the police were doing
their job this none of this would have
happened
yeah i agree with that
no okay so so you guys had michael
shellenberger on recently right yeah um
and and schellenberger in his book he
got what he claims is like the first at
length interview with carmen best who
was the uh she was two police in
seattle yeah um where where the the chas
chop protests happened um and she was
the one who got the order to give up the
fifth precinct and like retreat after
they took over the precinct and like
established their little autonomous zone
and when she says she was like this is
insane why are you telling me it's just
like very basic strategy you don't give
up a defended position to like a bunch
of
like rioters uh but she was ordered to
and i think i i think the reason for
that is that there was a sense that
police activity
and adver harmful police activity
manager justified was going to be
punished in the in the
public eye more than rioter activity was
so it's like when you go to the ice
cream shop and there's a little kid
screaming i want two scoops the mom's
like i'm sorry i'm sorry i'll give you
can you give me two more scoops he's
gonna he'll stop yelling if i do and
then he never stops yeah the police need
to come in and say
what you are doing is illegal right you
are hurting people and burning down
buildings and we will respond in
contrast but there's but there's no
there's a sense so so you talk about
you're talking about officers are
leaving over vaccine mandates um but you
know cops have been departing big city
departments uh either retiring or
resigning or most frequently as far as i
can tell going to other more friendly
jurisdictions and when you talk to them
what they say is basically like i don't
believe that the civilian leadership is
going to have my back i don't believe
that if i make the wrong call i think
they're gonna throw me under the bus
because my job is not popular there's an
element of that but there's also a lot
of police officers that are brown-nosing
and are saying you want me to leave you
want me to give this police precinct to
these crazy people sure have it yeah
there's police officers standing by i
remember watching police officers
twiddle their thumbs as like rioters
were just taking
new york city by storm it's really
simple then it's really simple the
system's broken the police aren't
policing the system doesn't work the
institution as we've we've known it and
want to protect is gone
and so now my fear is what what remains
are cops who are unwilling to enforce
against rioters because of bad optics
and because they won't get protected but
they're more than half they're more than
happy to arrest you for bearing arms
your constitutional right and they're
more than happy to uh find people and do
all of the administrative and
bureaucratic you know civil violation
stuff so all that's going to happen is
people are going to say
i was going like five over and i got
pulled over dude give me a break some
dude burned down my favorite restaurant
last night y'all did nothing for it so
if we're getting only the worst of
policing and it's not just the police's
fault because of it it's it's you know
also civilian leadership then what are
we actually defending well but i think
but i think it's a policy choice right
it's not the case that you know it's
it's not the case that necessarily this
needs to be to be the arrangement i
think it's the case that uh you know
there's when i start
talking about challenge book san
francisco you know i think one of the
things that comes with san francisco one
of the things that comes across is
really
a theme of contemporary progressivism is
that
socially deviant harmful behavior should
be tolerated and socially normal
behavior the average person should be
highly regulated that like if you want
to
do drugs and camp out on the sidewalk
and poop there
you can do that and we will pay you to
do it but
you everybody has to be subject to the
mass mandate everybody has to have their
sort of it is sort of banned ooh diaper
mandate yeah well
um
but i think you know i think i think
that that is that is a theory of urban
governance that's a progressive theory
of governance it's like and the the
thing that happened in the riots is that
the judgment call was made that it would
be more harmful to the legitimacy of the
city to see cops stopping riots than it
would just be to like let everything
burn and this is this propagates through
the media right npr published why
rioting is good uh everybody everyone's
a sense of luck in defense of looting
everybody was like well the insurance
companies will pay out so it's fine you
know they didn't hosing the hosing the
small business owners in the process you
know there's a there's a systematic
choice that was made to say
uh this deviant behavior will be
tolerated because the legitimacy of the
system is in question if it isn't
tolerant so you know i
i take your point about the
selectiveness i just think the problem
is like several layers levels up from
the cops per se and excuse me the
problem is like
terrible governance decisions i wanna i
wanna segue to the story we have this is
from fox news john oliver you know him
you'll love him says effing let police
officers who resist vaccine mandates
quit oliver argued resistance to vaccine
mandate sums up the core issue with
american police i'm sure it does but uh
we're we're segwaying segwaying from the
story that ultimately i think you know
we were talking about kyle written house
riots were talking about how the police
were standing down in the in the george
floyd riots i shouldn't say caught red
house rights the the george floyd riots
in which that was the jacob blake right
sorry yeah there's so many i get
confused sometimes um and we will soon
have the cop right house riots because
it's trial soon but the ultimate result
i think is gonna be cops quitting and so
we have this story which is really
interesting because police are quitting
a bunch of cops i think nypd is suing
over the vaccine mandate is that that's
great
chicago they're they're instructing the
officers to defy the mandate in
baltimore they're doing the same thing
the end result i think is going to be
cops quitting and here's the funny thing
we've we've long been saying now like
long as in the past couple of weeks the
left should be cheering for this they
wanted to defund the police abolish the
police they should be happy right turns
out they are fox news reports
last week tonight host john oliver took
aim at police officers who have yet to
get the vaccine
encouraging an effing quit quote the
police are supposed to be keeping the
public safe that is the point of their
jobs yet some don't seem to give much of
an ish about that
the liberal host single liberal host
singled out chicago and new york police
departments is fal uh falling under that
category cbd officers he noted resisted
uploading their vaccination statuses to
a portal over 20 officers are on no pay
status for refusing to comply he also
shared a video of a pair of nypd
officers who were seen removing a
commuter from the subway while they
themselves were unmasked that video was
actually kind of funny you see it a guy
in a mask yells at the cops to put a
mask on so they kick him out of the
subway that's crazy now
i think they are going to be happy i
think the left is effectively getting
their abolish the police through this
or defund them at the very least well
the abolish the police was never really
about abolishing the police it was about
a loyalty test it's making sure that the
police that are going to enforce their
edicts and their decrees are going to
stay there and the people who are going
to question it are of course going to be
kicked out and to me john oliver just
kind of confirmed how much of a loyalty
test these vax mandates are because a
lot of the people who are compliant a
lot of the people who are saying yes
i'll just do whatever you tell me are
the people who have taken the vacs some
of the people who can't take the vax or
don't want to take the facts or more
people who are not in line with the
state who questioned the state who still
are waiting for a lot of the data to
come in are people who are usually
skeptical of centralized authorities so
this to me is going to shift things in a
major dramatic way as of course there's
estimates that major cities could lose
one-third of their police forces because
of these mandates now when you have such
a huge loss with crime already going up
dramatically in cities this is a recipe
for a disaster and to me
only propagates a situation where of
course you're going to have politically
divided people more and more in certain
areas that may or may not go against
each other but we also have the news
that in florida the governor there ron
desantis is offering police officers
five thousand dollars in a signing bonus
if they refuse to take the vaccine and
relocate to florida and decide to be
police officers
indiana as well five thousand dollars
i don't know the number but there's uh
there's a push there's an indiana police
department that said that they're going
to welcome all the chicago police
officers
whichever police officers do not want to
take the vaccine
there's also a chicago police union
president that has been censored he
can't speak about the vaccine and what's
going on right now
but before he was censored by a court he
was making some pretty good points about
how a lot of these policies are
discriminatory how a lot of his officers
can't take the vaccine don't want to
take the vaccine have natural hurt
immunity he was making some really good
legitimate arguments but this is a major
issue and this mandate really will be
the true loyalty test that will separate
this nation into very very far away
political spectrums that hopefully are
able to stay together away from each
other peacefully there's a lot of
reasons
there's a lot of reasons why i thought
we should get away from the city we were
originally in the philadelphia area in
the jersey side
and uh we wanted to we almost bought a
building out there but sale kind of fell
through and it was just you know coveted
hit and then i thought you know what we
need space we need space we need to
cheat we need cheap space and we
shouldn't be in new jersey for a variety
of reasons one of those was that
as much as the cops we had were actually
really good we had we had a small
department with a handful of guys who
were they were quick they were they were
good people i talked to them you know i
would go into the
the the police station and talk to them
and they were great
moderate individuals not crazy trumpers
but certainly not authoritarian
and i just kind of thought
as things get crazy and they issue these
lockdown orders
and just north of where we lived was the
atlas gym where the cops actually came
and arrested arrested a guy i guess ian
smith right ian smith yeah he's the guy
who runs the gym and the initial the
first cops who came came there were like
we're not going to enforce this have a
nice day so they pulled cops from out of
town and i was like if they can do that
staying in this place is a really really
bad idea because the cops aren't going
to protect you they're going to oppress
you they're going to tell you that by
decree you can't leave your home you
can't go to the store you can't do these
things but they're not going to be there
when you need them
and so i thought you know what i would
rather be somewhere with no cops
so where we are right now
if you call the cops they might be here
in i don't know half an hour
longer
and where i live
good luck
it's a mountain
and so like my actual house and as much
as there's still risks there because
then everything's on you one thing i
noticed is that a lot of people have
said
people are actually reluctant to go up
into a mountain full of right-wing nut
jobs and commit crimes because everyone
there is armed to the teeth not that
anybody actually ever shoots anybody
they don't
but
people knowing that cops aren't going to
come
they don't climb a mountain and then try
to rob mountain full in the cities
people got a lot of guns in the cities
too though
yeah but not not usually the criminal
but look look in new jersey where i was
told explicitly by the police by
multiple departments that if someone
breaks into my house with a gun and
fires at me i have an obligation to flee
my own home yeah i'm like yeah yeah we
had someone try to break in and i'm like
what do i do the one cop goes i'd answer
the door the shotgun and so i looked it
up and i talked to him like oh but if
you use it you'll go to prison
what they said was
it's a semi-castle doctrine state what
that means is
you have an affirmative defense to shoot
someone who enters your home but you
will be arrested and charged first then
after you spend a night in jail and try
and get bailed out
bailed out which you might not you can
tell the judge why you were justified
and shooting the man who was trying to
kill you your friends and your family
and so i'm like
i'm going to have to argue in court that
i don't want to jump from the the we we
didn't have a back door the first floor
went over a balcony because it was on a
hill and i'm like so i got to jump off a
20 store you know for 20 feet up slide
down a pull a beam on my deck
or defend myself with i'm getting out of
this state this is insane west virginia
doesn't have those problems my friend
look so you know and and
that's good west virginia i wish there
was a lot of problems but does not have
a crime right that's a drug problem it's
a drug
big pharma it's not a drug problem it's
a big pharma problem
it's a drug problem huh it's a drug
problem yeah it's a drug problem that
was exacerbated by the big pharma ah now
yes i agree
with
you
after show but we could agree to
disagree
um uh
western doesn't but look most most crime
in america not all most primary
increasingly most americans concentrate
in cities hey that's because 80 of
people live in metropolitan areas um so
yeah you know you don't get a lot of
crime in rural west virginia because
nobody lives in a royal west virginia
nobody's come out and try to shoot you
um but you know
i think i think we have situated a
conversation in terms of like uh um we
saw the largest single year
percentage-wise and absolute terms
increase in homicide on record last year
uh average results rose 11
uh grand theft auto rose 11
nationwide it was much worse in
individual cities there are cities in
america baltimore chicago where the
homicide rate uh a particular homicide
rate for young black men exceeds a
hundred per hundred thousand that's
that the nationwide figure is like six
um that's enormously high rate so that's
crime crime is a real and increasing
problem in the united states uh by
comparison to the rest of the world
crime is an intolerable problem in the
united states twenty thousand fifty
twenty thousand people die a year of
homicide uh compare that rate to any
other developed nation it's
inconceivable that's thing one thing two
is the cultural
well we have a whole host of problems
but but from you know the root causes
don't matter what matters is what solves
the problem the answer is we got a lot
of really high quality evidence that
police are an effective tool for
reducing crime that if you put cops in
area crime declines in that area that if
you increase police forces crime goes
down we're not talking about just uh
just like minor crimes we're talking
about homicide but let's think about
those budgets for for a second i mean
i i've been to some countries where they
have
very they
they don't have armed cops you know like
south america as the garda they got a
lot of crime for sure in a lot of areas
but
you know what maybe it's
you look at scandinavia and they're
they're an example of how countries are
just very different the left likes to
use them as an example of how proper
placement can be done but then you're
like but they're small and they're
different in the united states we do
have a lot of cops we do have massive
policies we actually we actually so
first of all we don't have mass belief
we spend about three percent of all
dollars go to costs it's 100 excuse me
of all of all government spending across
local state and federal it's like what's
what's a comparable country with uh but
so so so the second point is we also
have a huge amount of money on cos the
second point is like in turn compared to
oecd countries costs per capita we're
like in the middle like we don't
actually we've way more prisoners
per capita our our prison capacity is
enormous uh our cops are like
middling um we absolutely there's
there's uh there's high quality
estimates there's going to be iron
chalfin at um
uh penn and another fellow whose name is
escaping me who do estimates of the
returns to policing and their argument
is that american cities are
systematically under policed uh for the
simple reason that like the amount of
money that we spend versus the
automotive we could save uh in real
value if fewer people murdered if there
were fewer cri there were fewer thefts
if they're fewer assaults uh
the the benefit the benefits that we
leave on the table dramatically outweigh
the amount of money we're spending now
well there's also another aspect to
entertain here and that's a lot of the
blue flu going around a lot of police
officers refusing to do their job
there's also the fact that the nypd has
you know almost the same amount of of
members as many militaries around the
world almost comparable to some of the
top militaries out there they have a
whole nypd intelligence unit that
literally has spies all over the world i
i would say that you know them spending
five billion dollars is a lot of money
for policing that many times they decide
not to do and participate or even
enforce the the the nypd okay a
militaries and police forces are apples
to oranges the number of things police
forces have to do much larger than the
senate things police forces have to do b
the new york city is a dramatic success
story in terms of public safety if you
look at violent crimes decline since the
1990s uh it's fallen dramatically across
the united states across major cities uh
homicide
crimes of violence etc
the decrease in new york city is 50
percent larger than other cities um
frank zimmering's our criminologist at
uc berkeley looks at all the relevant
factors that his book on this called uh
the city became safe and his argument is
that the rude explanation is basically
like there was a transition to more
policing and more and better policing in
new york city in the 90s like the nypd
there are certainly uh it is an enormous
department they spend a lot of time and
a lot of money on a lot of different
things um but it's hard to argue with
the results in terms of crime reduction
new york city in homicide rate turns for
example looks so much better than
comparable cities in the united states
it's insane how do you compare what
happened within the last few months and
last year when when crime and violence
has gone up so dramatically but but how
do you explain it i mean that's yes
i'm just asking you legitimately not
trying to contradict you know sure i
mean so so
the last year's trends are i think
alarming and it's unclear and there's a
live debate about what caused the
increase um this is
is it covered in these lockdowns i think
that there's some argument there but i
find it ultimately uncompelling for
reasons i can enumerate you know i do
think ultimately if you look at the
timing of when the increases happen if
you look at where they happen uh it
comes down to a concern this is back to
the conversation a concerted national
effort uh to delegitimize policing to
delegitimize the police like if if you
agree with the claim that cops reduce
crime uh that cop presence reduces crime
and then you start punishing cops for
showing up you start saying it's not
cool to be a cop it's we we hate the
cops we want to do fun the police cops
are racist pigs who want to murder us uh
you're going to lose policing capacity
when you lose policing capacity crime is
going to go up and that's what we saw
happen dramatically last year i'm not
sure that explains
let me let me just i think there's so
many variables that we could add on to
this but
uh there's also mass decarceration we
are my best estimates at like a tenth of
the jail population that we were in
march in february of 2020 um and that's
going to have an impact at the margins
um but like
i i i did some data analysis today i
looked at 9-1-1 calls in seattle because
there's a paper arguing looking at 911
calls as evidence that uh cops lost
legitimacy after george flayed's death
and then when calls went down
and one of the arguments that i make in
response to this paper is
uh data that looks at calls for service
by cops usually looks at both calls by
civilians like you pick up the phone and
call 9-1-1 you're like hey
uh there's a crime but also calls by
cops to uh
uh to the the center that manages
dispatch um
it's hard to disaggregate this data the
people that write these paper didn't
disagree with this day that assumed was
all civilians if you look in seattle
which is where you're really really good
numbers you look at calls from cops and
you get calls from civilians after the
week after george floyd's death calls
from civilians are flat they remain the
same calls and cops collapsed eighty
percent seventy percent
and have persisted consistently that's a
measure of police activity police
proactivity uh you can look at
employment in big cities you look at the
nypd you can look at minneapolis pd
collapsed you can look at stops and
arrests collapsed um by across metrics
in large not across the country but in
large cities there's good reason to
believe that uh
cops cops are doing less and less
practice and you can argue that that's
bad i think it's not great i would
prefer that cops like selflessly kept
going out and doing their jobs no matter
the incentives but you should also be
willing to say like actually the
incentives are pretty bad right now
to actually be a cop and do the cops
work yeah and some elements i definitely
agree with you and i think you did bring
up some important points uh what do you
think about the george soros appointed
district attorneys do you think that
they play a role in allowing a lot of
criminals to to be let off for a lot of
the violent crimes for a lot of the some
people say petty crimes but but i i
think there might be a correlation with
a lot of people being sent off
while they're committing hard crimes
meanwhile political crime i would argue
is being prosecuted very heavy-handedly
especially if you believe in the wrong
kind of political ideology yeah well let
me i want to jump to a story here
actually because this is a really really
crazy tweet i saw from mike cernovich
cervich says judge amy jackson released
a j6 defendant from pretrial custody
after he disavowed trump in a letter and
his lawyer suggested a political
conversion i've never seen anything like
this ever
so here's a guy who's been in jail now
for what is it going on nine months
and there's been horrifying conditions
there's a guy whose hand was broken
medical treatment the judge held the it
was the warden and the
director
and the director of the department of
corrections i guess got held in contempt
and now you've they've seen the writing
on the wall
disavow the politics you previously
supported and they'll let you go this is
re-education right this is the state of
of our current political and law
enforcement environment if that's the
case
i think we are
are we already beyond that that that red
line passed the road yeah september 11th
in the patriot act was the red line when
they signed the patriot act they crossed
the red line
there's there's a lot of stuff that
happened throughout history though
there's a lot there that's true i think
that was a major turning point but there
were other things that people could you
could take across on the gulf of tonkin
crossing they can arrest anyone at any
time with the patriots and there was the
enemy
indefinitely for no reason
what that's insane
well there you go i guess they're doing
it well i i would just kind of you know
go back to the point what do you think
about the kind of prosecution of
political crimes while george soros's
appointed ages usually let a lot of
criminals off yeah i mean you know i
think i think the progressive prosecutor
movement you know it's it's harder to
track um what's going on one of the
reasons you're able to criticize cop
people able to criticize customer
effectively is because big city police
departments release a lot of information
uh da's offices are not actually that
transparent like you they're some of
these progressive offices are getting a
little more transparent which is nice
because you can see where they're not
prosecuting uh larry krasner not
pursuing gun crimes in philadelphia for
example um
it's hard to figure out what the impact
has been in the short run but i suspect
in the long run like petty crime will
flourish if you look at a city like san
francisco what has happened with
shoplifting there is clearly in part a
byproduct of the state's decision to say
that a theft under 950 will no longer be
treated as felonious theft it's
partially a product of decisions by da's
like chester boudin to say uh these
offenses are not a serious issue these
minor offenses and this goes back to the
point i was making earlier it's like if
behavior is perceived as
socially deviant in certain ways then
it's considered acceptable and not
deserving of punishment if behavior is
perceived as you know i don't have a
strong opinion about this particular
case not in all the details but i think
it is certainly true that people can be
prosecuted if not by the law and
certainly public opinion
for uh opinions which are not deemed
acceptable by the mainstream media by
public commentators uh in a way that
they are not for doing things like petty
shoplifting across uh running a
shoplifting room across san francisco i
think a lot of cops are uh also
disenfranchised i think there's a lot
more of the blue flu going around than
we even know about i think that's one of
the reasons but but also it's kind of
understandable because a lot of these
cops are like okay i booked this guy i
risked my life to put him in jail and
then he's just let out the next day what
the hell is going on here why should i
even risk my safety to do this again
when everyone also hates me so i think
there's an element of this that should
be talked about and considering when you
talk about something like bail reform um
and you know they're they're better you
know i think i think there's a stronger
even the cash bail is not a great idea
that you you shouldn't be let in or out
of jail because of your ability to pay
as opposed to your risk to society which
is something you can do but you look at
a
new york state's original bail law which
rather than assessing risk uh just sort
of released people created a strong
presumption of release for many classes
of offenders and the effect was you were
seeing guys get picked up and arrested
20 times and they were out the very next
day and it's like what is the you're
right what is the point of running a
criminal justice system uh and my my
colleague rafael mangual at the
manhattan institute likes to say
criminals don't specialize the guy who
is getting picked up for like uh jumping
a turn style or republican decency he's
the same guy who thinks it's cool to
jack a car and that's the same there's a
case in a terrible case in san francisco
guy stole a guy was out on bail thanks
chess boudin stole a car shoot him in
prison shoot him in jail uh and ran over
and killed two pedestrians uh an old
lady and her and her daughter her her
niece um
it's it's it's a horrible case and you
know what happens is that criminals
don't specialize the guy the guy who
gets who gets stuck in jail for one
thing will it gets let out
he is often the guy who goes on to get a
more serious offense either
there are powerful elites that know
they're burning the country to the
ground and they like the fact that many
of these leftist and establishment
democrat types are too stupid to read
what's going on or
they're all really stupid and just
marching in lockstep because they're not
smart enough to realize they're burning
the place to the ground you look at the
policies in the cities with these soros
da's and they're like i'm going to
release this violent offender and then
he kills somebody and it's like well who
could have seen that coming i kind of
agree with you charles that there are
like two types of people one that
respects the law and one that doesn't
respect the law but then i see people
like julian assange and edward snowden
who they made specific crimes that you
got to wonder is that law just that they
violated like was hitler's restoration
of the professional civil service of
april 7 1933 which excluded jews from
civil service was that a just law
i mean no no it wasn't i like i like
being the civil servant the criminals
that violated that law weren't the kind
of criminals that would mug someone yes
sure and and even even uh not nazi
germany can create we can create unjust
laws we live in just laws now i think so
uh but like part of the principle of
living in the republic is that we don't
get to flout laws that we don't like
right like like we live under we we have
some agreement um i think i think it is
i think it is
like it's not necessarily that
everybody's malicious not even
necessarily that even stupid it's like i
think about the mayor of seattle jenny
durkin durkheim i forget her last name
um who looked at the at the chas chop
zone and was like this is the summer of
love
like these people they went to our house
you know the people who are getting shot
and murdered in europe and chicago and
baltimore are not the people who are
running the city uh 90 plus percent of
homicide victims in new york city every
year are black or hispanic they're not
the people who are running you know eric
adams is a black dude he lives in new
jersey but he is a black dude um but
generally he he's not coming from the
context of the people who are getting
shot so i think a lot of it comes down
to sort of abstraction into political
ideology it's like i believe that these
people are at the center of systems of
oppression so i just need to sort of
liberate them from this it's like nah i
don't think it's that genuine i don't
think it's that loving and caring these
people don't live with them they're not
in the same communities and i agree with
that particular point but to think that
a lot of these people making these
policies are not seeing the effects of
them i think
is not a realistic point i think they
know exactly what they're doing i think
it's leading to a system that they want
a situation that they want that has
people fighting each other arguing with
each other has people unhappy has people
unhealthy has people being victims of
crime more than ever and i think that
benefits a system that thrives off of
that and and i think i would i would
argue that rather than i know what's
right i'm going to help these people
they pretend to say that but at the end
of the day they know that they're not
doing that
i i don't like that uh
that rep small group of representatives
are in charge of making the laws anymore
it doesn't seem right with 350 million
of us that have access to the internet
and doing this together that we've given
it up the power to like 600 people it
doesn't make any sense because you see
these bastardized laws that they're
creating and enforcing like the ndaa
they can just grab someone out of their
house and stick them in guantanamo for
as long as they want that's that's not
when they just when they took a what are
they like a red what was it a red writer
a little wagon with 5 000 pages for the
omnimus bill and they're like carding it
into the congress and they're like
nobody read it nobody's gonna read it
let's make it a law
that's a that's a functional system
right there huh
no no it's not
thank you thank you
good point idiot i appreciate that but i
think there's a bigger conversation to
be had here because
when we look at the statistics
especially within the last few months
the people are getting screwed over here
people are getting hurt more than ever
people are being victims of crime more
than ever people are becoming more
unhealthy more unhappy uh
you know they're getting robbed
economically every step of the way here
and and a lot of this comes from a lot
of these politicians saying i'm going to
help you they're not helping you they
know they're not helping you because
look who's benefiting off of this a lot
of multinational corporate elites a lot
of billionaires who are making raking in
record profits while everyone else is
having a harder time making it by to be
fair i mean
you can just follow nancy pelosi and buy
what she buy the stocks that she buys
yes right and and and and come on when
all this went down it should have been
obvious to everybody that you could just
buy the stock for pfizer johnson johnson
moderna amazon is walmart's private
though is walmart's not publicly traded
i think it's private you could about
amazon stock that went through the roof
so of course it was benefiting the
billionaires
but it was also benefiting the
millionaires
see so if you were a millionaire you
were doing all right oh you guys are
talking about working-class people oh
yeah the working-class people were
screwed completely you know i think i
think sort of my my
response to that point is so like this
is not the worst violent crime has been
in the united states right there there's
a
uh for viewers under the age of 30 who
do not remember i i'm under the age of
30 but like for viewers who do not
remember the 80s and 90s um
homicide rates were substantially higher
volume crime rates uh you couldn't walk
through times square in new york city
because it was like a den of
prostitution iniquity well hold on do
you know why homicide rates were
substantially higher before 2007
why cell phones
all right lack of cell phones so
what one thing that needs to be
considered that um when it comes to
tracking the homicide rate is that once
cell phones became ubiquitous
violent crime that resulted in death
became violent crime that didn't result
in death because people could call 9-1-1
immediately whereas before this
they would rush to find a phone and so
what ends up happening is there's an
illusion that there's a major drop-off
in violent crime when there isn't
there's it's the same there's a similar
level of crime it is going down yeah so
so the violent crime rate declined
substantially by 1994 the homicide rate
falls from 1989
um and actually there's a leveling off
around the great recession in the in the
violent crime rate of that in the house
that actually meant that that violent
crime was skyrocketing right or so i'll
put it this way
homicides changed because of cell phones
into attempted murders and so you had
less people dying that substantially
changed the nature of how crimes were
being reported so when you look at the
great recession it's like oh it's flat
actually people are surviving the
violent attacks i mean you would you
would you would expect an increase in
the aggregate in the aggravated solar
violent crime rate then which doesn't
happen i mean i i i believe that
improvements in trauma medicine and uh
so so there's a great um you look at uh
what's his name
uh stephen pinker that it could be that
people weren't reporting the crimes yeah
there's a corpse on the ground it gets
reported yeah so so i mean
the homicide is sort of the the
historically most reliable indicator
right because there's a corpse on the
ground um but like we can plausibly
compare the 1990s to the early 2000s we
say that violent crime is substantially
lower um you can you can quibble about
like what the what the direction of that
is with the magnitude of the change but
it's like it's definitely down the point
that i wanted to make is that like
violent crime rose in the 60s and 70s uh
i think largely for ideological reasons
they're
all of the same ideas were in the water
that we should convert the the the
criminal systems would be primarily
rehabilitative that cops were violent
and dangerous and racist and that they
needed to be like frankly they were more
violent and dangerous and racist than
they are now like cops were way worse 50
years ago than they are today 60 years
ago than they are today um
that uh that what we really needed was
like a more therapeutic state that like
looked after everybody and these ideas
like had enormous currency in the 60s
and 70s uh and there was a there was a
retraction of criminal justice capacity
there was a retraction of uh policing
and incarcerate incarceral capacity and
the result was predictable like these
ideas go in and out of fashion they come
in and out of style and i think that
they're coming back now well so i want
to ask you um you know before the show
you were saying that you think the
republicans are going to win
they're going to they're going to
do you think the republicans are going
to win in 2022 yeah i mean i think all i
think all the fundamentals are there
right like uh joe biden's joe brown's
approval is underwater uh uh
democratic president takes office the
gop usually wins in the file usually
gains seats in the following election
uh
the gop could totally blow it but i
think if they play their cards right
then kevin mccarthy speaker i think
that's likely it's it's a narrow margin
in the house as is and what do you think
what do you think the first thing
they'll do is oh well i'm not gonna say
that i'm not just the first thing
they'll do right right right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right right right i don't know that's
why i'm asking specifically do you think
okay i'll just get into it you said
they're going to impeach bite oh yeah i
want that to happen but do you think
it'll be the first thing they do like
you think they'll be like we're doing it
we're impeaching this guy
uh no it'll be something like
it it'll be a messaging bill right it's
like when the democrats who took the
house the first thing they did was pass
hr1 the voting rights act which is part
of the broader messaging schema of
republicans hate democracy where the
pro-democracy party vote for us um
i don't know what the what the gop's day
one bill is like you know probably
something about inflation or controlling
inflation or the economy um i do think i
do think that the precedent has been
said that impeachment is a political
tool especially when you are in control
of the house but not the senec so you
know it doesn't matter i think they're
totally gonna beat joe biden because
that's what you're just gonna do now but
do you think they have a good case for
impeaching him or do you think it's
gonna be a lie yeah we'll figure it out
i think they'll figure it out i think i
think it's gonna be ukraine i think it's
going to be the laptop the emails
the photos of joe biden the the emails
where he's sharing his bank account with
his son and collecting money and then
they're spending money on each other's
behalf there's there's no specificity in
the constitution of what high crimes and
misdemeanors actually means it's
whatever congress says and it's
unreviewable by the supreme court or any
other court it's purely a political
decision so uh they'll find something
because it'll be a great way
to put joe biden on try joe biden on
trial in the in the public eye and that
will line up 2024. do you think he
should be impeached
uh
no
no no really you don't think like all
the stuff he did with ukraine and uh
rosemont seneca and all that stuff
that's now basically confirmed his
hunter biden connected bank account that
they were doing absolutely illicit and
legal things with i don't have i don't
have
strong opinions about uh about the
details there
i do
okay and i think that there's there's a
big argument to make here well i'm sure
i'm sure i'm here for criminals so the
house traveling caucus will be happy to
call you in as an expert witness on the
impeachment here no no no no i don't i
don't i don't trust the republicans as
far as i could see them or throw them uh
and i don't i don't think they're even
going to go going to go with impeachment
i think they're going to be talk about
this but i don't think they have that
much of a backbone and spine to even do
that or even to match the democrats on
many of their aggressive motions
i think i think the base wants a lot of
things and i think republicans there are
there to placate them pat them on the
back saying yes in just a little bit
just a little bit more just you know
it'll be we'll just give you anything
you want to just just vote for us and
then
you they're bad but they're you know i
think that's the game that they're
playing here that's my own personal
opinion and i might and i might be wrong
the great thing about controlling the
house representatives is that you're
totally powerless right
as as i was saying as i was saying
before every time the democrats who take
the house they're like oh we're gonna
pass medicare for all we're gonna we're
gonna do it in the house like this is
and if you vote for us you're gonna get
better and then you know they they win
and they go uh maybe not on the medicare
for all thing maybe we're not gonna do
that because they know it's politically
popular and they can make an empty
promise and the same thing is true uh
here here's my bet day one bill there's
gonna be a federal there should be
federal law banning crt in schools it's
not clear what that means
but they sure are gonna ban it and
that's gonna be you know they can
prohibit federal funding for local
schools if they get criticized
then it will move to the senate but then
biden will veto it right well
we'll clear the filibuster so it won't
matter right yeah like you you can do
these messaging bills you can do these
and impeachment imp and this goes back
to the point like impeachment is part of
the political process now it's just like
a thing that you do to show that the
other team is bad i'm not even convinced
republicans are going to win right so
i i we were talking about talking about
this before we started the show you know
538 and a bunch of other outlets say
that historically the opposing party
should win and there's data to suggest
it may happen
but there have been so many rule changes
with like universal mail-in voting which
massively advantages democrats for one
simple reason most of you probably heard
me say it but it's this simple when it
comes to ground activism knocking on
doors democrats can hit a thousand
families in one apartment complex
whereas republicans gotta drive that
means that democrats can clear way more
ground during advocacy than a republican
ever could that's gonna be massive for
them oh that's your ballot right there
fill it out put in your mailbox you're
done republicans knock on doors they can
hit a tenth of the houses
republicans have completely ignored this
those that have been paying attention to
the election have mostly been concerned
about the audits which have been long
drawn out and
some interesting information comes out
that ultimately
no one moves on and nothing happens
meanwhile we can actively see the rules
they're trying to change hr1 like you
mentioned and that like the time
magazine article the shadow campaign to
save the election
they we know exactly what they're doing
to advantage themselves and republicans
don't care
so maybe they should win but maybe they
won't here's the dirty little secret
about most voting uh about most changes
to the electoral structure they don't
have a huge impact my favorite example
of this is voter id right like voter id
is this like great racist plot to
destroy the democratic electorate and if
if the republicans get to pass voter id
uh then then it will be the end of
democracy as we know it except that
actual studies of voter id laws that
have been implemented it has no impact
on turnout like the the the results are
exactly the same and this is true avr
has an impact automatic voter
registration motor voter has an impact
um i don't nobody knows what malen's
going to do because it's just like so
weird um compared to like sesquienti
like people voting from home is just so
different after cobid um but i think in
general if you're too lazy to vote you
don't vote if you're not if you're
motivated to vote you like go stand in
the line and accept people universe and
mail in voting universal mail and voting
someone could not knock on your door and
you get up and your eyes are half close
and they go hi i'm with such a touch
campaign did you vote yet and they go no
like well there's your ballot right
there why don't you fill it out they're
gonna go
i guess or how about the mom walks in
and goes kids did you vote yet and
they're like no mom i don't care just
fill out your vote so we're not getting
ice cream and they go fine whatever what
am i voting for just vote democrat okay
they fill it out
it's the ground game i think is most
important because i've i've seen these
these organizations i actually did uh i
i volunteered to register registered
people to vote at a concert for death
cab for cutie back in this was like the
obama uh period and so guess what every
person there was voting democrat so
you've got people like scott pressler
he's registering republicans he's very
effective and boy do they go after him
but the democrats can easily do voter
registration and when you've got your
mail-in ballot sitting right there on
your table and you knock on the door
look it may not be the lazy people who
they're gonna get but there could be
negligent people who go you know i was
gonna well won't you fill it out right
now okay sure i guess and then just put
in your mailbox mailman will come take
it that's gonna massively increase
turnout i mean the interesting question
to me is is
well so a we didn't see a huge increase
in turnout in 2020. so i it could change
in 2022 although like like who votes and
the who votes in the off-cycle election
the interesting question to me is like
the historical norm is that if if
turnout is high democrats win tryna slow
republicans win for the simple reason
that uh the republican base is smaller
but it's more has a higher priority vote
it's like old people have nothing better
to do than vote the republican the
democratic base is larger but they're
lower principal vote it's like young
people who are like out partying and a
death cab for cutie concerts rather than
voting um but i think that that is that
is shifting as the electorate polarizes
along educated lines um we at the
manhattan institute just put out a paper
that i think is really interesting
talking about on cycling or off cycling
elections which is like um so like uh
virginia the the big race is coming up
next uh next week virginia holds its
elections off cycle which is like in
2021 20 in odd numbered years um and
that massively depresses turnout or like
school board elections are usually held
in 18 states they're mandatorily off
cycle local elections happen in opposite
years and you get these turnouts
larry krasner who's the progressive
prosecutor who just won the democratic
primary in philadelphia he was like this
is like seen as a major victory for the
progress prosecutor 18 of eligible
democrats voted in the philadelphia d.a
primary uh in i think march uh ten
percent of them voted ten percent points
voted for krasner eight percent voted
for carlos vega as a krasner one it's
like that's not a referendum um so you
know we're talking about when you when
you answer when you bring elections on
cycle you dramatically change the
electorate i'm interested in if you
boost voter turnout does that now with
the changing
party composition actually start to if
not benefit republicans then
shift the balance in interesting ways i
think i think that's a real possibility
with the republican party capturing
lower education voters the party
capturing just otherwise disenfranchised
voters if you make it easier for those
people to vote how does that shake
things up i think it's unclear virginia
is going to be a huge sign of things to
come we'll see
neck and neck in virginia yeah but
virginia's gone full blue yeah it's
really funny you know the area we're in
it's a tri-state it's maryland virginia
west virginia and boy do people talk
very poorly about virginia around here
maryland is already bad but these
counties up here are are very red
where we are right now we're one of the
counties that just found that letter
saying we want to join west virginia you
go over the river to virginia and you're
in loudoun county
when you know all about loudoun oh yeah
and then so it's a very conflicted area
you cross the river into west virginia
and it's red i don't know if loudon is
red or blue but it's it's conflicted and
considering the state itself is is super
majority now uh or it's not i don't know
super majority but majority democrat
it's very very interesting to see the
sentiment
of these people in these areas
one of the interesting things about west
virginia is that crt is getting to those
schools as well
it's because these activists are going
and infiltrating rural areas on purpose
i guess it'll be interesting to see how
that plays out in the next few years
when it comes to elections but i think
virginia's election is going to be
i don't know kind of uh um
what's the right word it's about weather
right yeah yeah i mean and and it's it's
really interesting how the two
candidates are playing it right like
mcauliffe is betting on virginia is a
blue state and it's the kind of blue
state that's motivated to turn out
because i hate donald trump but his
agenda is glenn youngkin is donald trump
in the flesh he's he's just the local
like you think you know i'm terming
terry mcauliffe is like uh he's a career
politician he's been governor of
virginia before uh he can't keep
straight any of a number of things
including how many people in the state
have covered at any given time um and
but that that's his bet i think glenn
youngkin's bet is
he's lighting on the policy details he
thinks people are mad about these red
meat issues you think people matter at
crt and that that will get enough
turnout in the non-nova counties to push
it over and you know is it going to
happen for him i don't know i think
you're right that everyone wants it to
be a bellwether i'm not
sure
i think if glenn young can lose his i'm
i still think republicans are going to
take the house it doesn't cause him to
revise that i think if glenn young can
wins real quicks are totally gonna
retake the house by a big march it's
gonna be interesting it i mean this is a
big election and i think you're right
tim i mean there's a reason barack
obama's getting involved here even
making comments about what happened in
loudoun country county
which we can't even talk about here on
youtube uh because of the adult nature
of what happened in that school
um but barack obama said you know it's
just parents overreacting and clearly a
court ruled and saw things a totally
different way the facts speak of a
totally different story and i think that
story that we can't even talk about i
think there's another reason why we
can't talk about it i think it might be
even politically motivated is is is
shocking a lot of people in virginia and
is motivating them to vote against the
current establishment against people
like barack obama that are just
conflating it with oh it's just parents
being crazy let's we'll talk about the
member segment because this is a
particularly graphic story and if we
want to get the full details out it's
not something you want your kids to hear
and it's also something that youtube
probably wouldn't be happy with because
it involves a lot of sensitive uh
it involves a lot of really disgusting
issues i'll put it that way but i do
want to i do want to talk about
something while we're still live on this
show and it's a hard segue but this is
really important from timcats.com rumble
acquires locals in a bid to expand
creator economy the company wants to
foster high quality content by giving
creators control of their content and
data
very interesting move for those that
don't know rumble is a very popular
video player it's alternative to youtube
essentially it's got a lot of
independent and and conservative voices
on it and it's considered kind of like
an alternative to youtube there have
been many rumble seems to be doing
really well and seems to have large
coffers as it were and locals is
basically dave rubin's answer to patreon
so now rumble has acquired locals i
don't know what this will mean for the
people of locals who have their accounts
there
but wow
this uh this is a fast move we have a
quote actually
quote we felt there was an opportunity
to fairly serve everyone by providing
the same tools large creators have
without preferencing rumble told tim
cast via email based on the premise that
small creators like friends and family
were no longer being prioritized on
platforms like youtube privately owned
rumble launched in 2013. the company's
creators felt large platforms focus on
multi-channel networks large
corporations and brands
unlike other platforms creators using
locals own not only their own content
but also the community data the data can
be analyzed to better understand and
engage with the creator audience with
more insight into who they are reaching
creators can expand their work and
continue to generate revenue without
outside influence instead they'll use
subscription model locals has built
this is particularly interesting ian
what do you think about that i think the
consolidation of corporate power is
often done with good intentions dave
rubin sold you out
he got a bunch of big big popular people
in there with and by using his personal
brand and his trust and then he sold you
out he made i don't know they haven't
released how much money he got paid to
sell you out but he is up
what do you mean by sell them i mean
that he just got paid a lot of money and
got an offer he couldn't refuse to give
now control of all these people trusted
dave they trusted you right and now now
they have no choice but to be owned
their data is now owned by rumble this
is what google bought youtube i remember
that happening in 2008.
well so they say specifically that uh
you own your community data that's what
they say i don't know anything about
this deal to be honest i think the
bigger issue i have with um look i i
think you know i tweeted out congrats to
him for pulling it off i think it's
fantastic i think there's uh there's
some critiques we have i think it's good
that the independent
tech environment is growing larger and
more powerful and ultimately this will
be good because there needs to be market
competition against youtube and patreon
and silicon valley this is what we're
seeing however that being said
i don't like
any of how the system is operating and
it's not anything personal with rumble
uh we use we use rumble we uh um i'm i
think i think locals is fantastic
but the whole time
the patreon fiasco happened this is
basically you know patreon bans carl
benjamin they banned lauren southern
first and they banned carl benjamin they
basically nuked people's income without
warning or notice
overnight one day you know carl wakes up
his accounts deleted all his money is
gone
so what what ends up happening is we see
alternatives emerge saying we're going
to create centralized subscription
models just like patreon but with our
own unique version of it
and it's the exact same problem i'm not
a fan of it michael malus dave sold you
out dude
i hope that you got paid for this too
mike i hope that all the people on
locals got a percentage of this buyout
because it's your data that was sold
oh ian you get pissed this is why we're
building decentralized
technology where you can own your own
data and host your own stuff
i agree
i mean i've always been skeptical even
over the alternatives because there have
been alternative social media platforms
that came and went sold their viewers
deleted their content and then just
rebranded and started new again i'm like
wait wait hold on what about my old
content that i uploaded there like oh
it's gone i'm like
you know there's a lot of you know pump
and dump cryptocurrencies also out there
there's a lot of bad things that's why i
always prioritized building my own
platform my own email list that's why i
have lucconsensor.com you have
timcast.com and i think this is the way
that it's going to go decentralized and
i think if you ever put your hope in a
centralized system or somebody else to
take care of something for you i think
there's a bigger chance you're always
going to be let down i want to put
subsec out of business
i want to put locals out of business i
want to put patreon out of business i
want to put all of these subscription
service services out of business
now that is just me being kind of
hyperbolic but the point i'm making is
you know for one ian spearheading with
with many other people the the on
foundations work which is creating
decentralized open source versions of
these tools which means
it's not just that you'll own your data
you'll own the domain you'll own the
server space it'll be yours and you can
set it up or you can join like a node
where someone's got centralized server
space and then you can you know
piggyback on it the issue i have here is
that the solution to the problems we
faced even by someone like dave rubin
has been to recreate the same system
which creates the same vulnerabilities
and the same problems
now i don't know if i would go as far as
you to say that they were sold out
because i don't know how this negatively
impacts someone like michael mouse yeah
me too i am open to following this i'm
really going to in the next coming weeks
because i want to know all the terms of
the contract that are going to be as
much as possibly publicly available
because maybe the people are going to
make out like bandits on this as well as
dave but dave i had a lot of faith in
you and i gave you the benefit of the
doubt i thought you were going to hold
on to locals for the next 20 or 30 years
and really do this at least try and do
it right
this is devastating to me so one thing i
think you can consider is um
and look look i know uh
dave i know the guys at rumble one thing
you consider you should consider is that
when you sign up for a service like
patreon subscribe star or uh or locals
you're locked in whether intentionally
or not it's not so much they own the
data and they can claim you own the data
it's that
if you build up say 3 000 paying
subscribers on someone else's platform
and they're getting a cut of that you
can't leave they own you forever
now you can beg your your your
subscribers and your followers like guys
i'm gonna be moving to a new platform
please subscribe there but i saw this i
saw what happened with patreon when
patreon nuked carl benjamin and all of
his people a bunch of his fans started
quitting and cancelling subscriptions
and hit everybody so i went from having
i think we had a few thousand people
donating
and then when everyone's like sorry tim
i can't support patreon i said i set up
subscribe star an alternate platform you
can you can support me there and the
attrition was massive people did not
move over so when i saw that i said
centralizing people's subscriber base
onto someone else's platform will always
be negative towards these individuals
and what we need is a decentralized easy
to install package that someone can make
their own version at timcast.com the
first thing we did was we hired a guy to
make a very simple website cost us a
decent amount of money and then we
started posting members only content as
if it was any other you know private
subscription service
the amount of money that we would have
spent if we went with any of these
platforms be it patreon local
subscribers or otherwise
it was
70 percent higher i'll put it that way
when i start when i saw how much they
charge people to use their platforms i
was just like they are
extracting value from people like locals
they're taking what like eight to twenty
percent of your
income they take some percent of your
monthly income and now that's going to
rumble and if the value of that them
taking a large percent of the income is
that the network effect of locals so if
you leave locals you lose that network
effect
one of the things i think you know
could be considered as well is that uh
rumble recently hired a bunch of video
creators and personalities to make
content for them i wonder who they're
going to sell their company too with the
with the acquisition of locals
theoretically the integration would
undercut any of their creators for
making similar similar deals now google
can buy rumble and now you're going to
make out like a bandit chris pavlov
pavlovsky good job
i know chris i don't think this is
ultimately a bad thing i just don't like
the idea of centralizing people's
interests corporate consolidation is not
inherently bad it's just super dangerous
for liberty we use rumble i think
rumble's great yeah it's fast it's cheap
it's effective
there's no censorship my bigger concern
is people's income being centralized and
then sold around right so so here's what
you got to understand
uh and again with all due respect to
today i think i said congratulations
because i think it's i think you know he
did great work and alternative media
growing bigger and more powerful is a
good thing my my answer is more like my
view of this is
you don't want to work for somebody and
it's already bad enough there's youtube
rules there's twitter rules whatever
making your own space where you can
control it is good
but if the idea of locals was that you
would control your own community but
that but that dave could then sell your
community to somebody else completely
undercuts
what i guess the the the story was
supposed to be
i don't want someone to be like hey i'm
running a service if you use it i
guarantee you x and then i'll say okay
great like you said oh dave's going to
own this forever i trust him
and then he sells it and now you don't
know who you're answering to now you
don't know what terms will change and
they could i don't like the idea that
your income your subscribers your fans
can be sold to someone else
i'm just crazy i i'm still waiting for
all the details to come out of this um
and they should be coming out if they
don't that's when people should be
worried but let's see exactly what the
deal was let's see what the contracts
are going to be let's see how they're
going to change let's see the terms it's
going to be interesting to see how this
went down i think it's a good thing look
i'm not trying to run on the parade but
i you know i think being critical is
fair because i've been critical of the
centralized subscription services from
the beginning regardless of who owns it
in a lot of ways google buying youtube
was fantastic for creators because they
created the partner they were able to
subsidize and create the partner program
and start paying people youtube wasn't
able to do that when it was chat hurley
but
the downside then is google's corporate
censorship model took over
the fear would be if you know rumble
sold which i don't think it will though
well no one ever thinks it's going to
happen that's true but it's totally
legally allowed to i did not think
locals would sell i did not yeah to
anybody and then they do
but
i'm not i'm not i'm not too worried
about this i i think ultimately look
rumble i think is fantastic and i think
them gaining more uh more power in this
space to help push back against the
censorship and the big tech oligarchy
it's a good thing it's a good thing
um i'll just put it this way
i don't i've talked to people about
locals and i'm like i think it's
fantastic that dave was like patreon
censorious and bad so we need our own
space and he made it and then other
people used it i just wish people like
michael mals for instance decided to
write a check for a grand to just make
his own version of it and not give away
10 of his revenue i just don't
understand this this is what this is
what drives me insane is that tulsi
gabbard michael malus you know who uh
other people who are using locals and
again no disrespect to locals but just
in terms of these people
you go online you say web dev they'll
say we can make you this exact thing for
a thousand bucks we'll have it done in
overnight
finger snap
now i just don't get it but i guess
people have said they want the network
that it's like you're on this platform
other people are on it
i just wish people were more
freedom oriented i guess and and and
took the took the responsibility upon
their shoulders and protected their
assets and had more control maybe that's
just me maybe i'm too uh arrogant and i
refuse to like give up
you know
anything that i'm doing to anybody else
for any reason hey i had i had my
subscription service for seven years
so i i believe in that idea as well
decentralization is the idea that i
think we should be promoting but we
could promote it by giving by being
examples of it rather than just
following the herd and the flock i just
i i just don't understand it guys i'm
just going to say one more time
if
most of these services have a 10 feet
that means if you have 100 patrons
and they're each giving you 10 bucks
you're getting a thousand bucks a month
you're giving a hundred dollars per
month to that company
now that can make sense if you're not
not expecting to have a large following
but let's say you have
a thousand people giving you money now
you have you know 10 bucks per person
you're getting 10 000 you're giving a
thousand dollars per month to these
platforms for what for a one-time fee of
a thousand bucks a web dev can make you
a simplified version of this that's why
i'm like we need to make free and open
source software that we can just give to
people and they can get their domain
12 bucks they can get some server space
50 bucks
spend a one-time rate if they've got you
know
i guess the problem is people are like
how do i even get to the point where
1000 bucks unless i use someone else's
infrastructure and i'm like
save up
uh save up money
do what you can because then you hire a
guy for for a thousand bucks and maybe
you can even get cheaper if you've got a
friend or you can learn how to do it
yourself it is it is plugins it is
wordpress it is plugins it is simplified
you can make it server space is
extremely expensive you know there's no
there's no perfect solution which is why
one hasn't been created yet but keep
know that if someone else has your data
they're gonna sell it and they may not
but
think like that the amount of money that
we would have given away timcast.com if
we went with any one of these platforms
i i i it's
it is it is substantial we could have
started six companies with the money
we've saved
easily that's what's crazy to me i know
the cost of bandwidth i know the cost of
development and i i look and i'm just
like
how come we don't have someone going to
these these individuals like michael
mall is friends who are a huge fan of
being like hey michael here's a guy pay
him one time he'll make the site for you
and you don't have to give anyone money
ever again it's all yours don't give it
away i just don't understand that i just
don't get it but you know what look look
that's just me
you know i see something and i don't
understand why people are just giving
things away
instead of trying to to build up
something that is secure and unbannable
but hopefully i'll put it this way
before we go to super chats
what we're working on should should put
these companies out of business all of
them i don't care their political
ideology i'm not not necessarily because
some people won't want to buy a server
space and install a package
but we're going to make it so that
instead of having to worry about a
thousand bucks to hire the web dev
all that work's gonna be done and you're
gonna just click a link and it's gonna
say drag and drop this into your onto
your into your server file here's how
you do it and then boom you have a
subscription service website done and
here's all the other people using the
service and then you can pick who you
want to see you can whitelist and
blacklist corporations it's going to be
great yeah it's all free free 100 and
that means the only costs you'll have is
the credit card exchange rate which
server costs which can be insane so the
that's that's a big part of this is
server costs figuring out how to mesh
network servers but it will use a
library or have it local it'll always be
cheaper than what you'd give to a
private company that's seeking to profit
off of your subscriber base yes
and especially as it scales up they do a
lot of the work for you that's what
makes those companies look nice but
that's what we're doing we're doing the
work for you but we also do have
torrent based uh video hosting
and there are other platforms that can
do extremely low cost i mean
interestingly rumble is one of them and
do very low cost hosting and so at a
certain point
you don't need these services to
function like this
it's it's it's it's like wordpress
plugins man i'm not even kidding how
ridiculously easy it is to set up you
you get a wordpress you download
subscriber plug-in
double-click it and you're done we're
just simplifying it making it as easy as
possible like one click and the thing's
all set to go but it already is easy
that's just me man i don't know look i i
look at the culture war i look at some
of i look at so many of these these uh
personalities who are making tons of
money and i'm like
why don't they have 10 more shows the
young turks have a network where they've
got a dozen shows they make money and
they dish it out to all these people
then they get investors and they dish it
out to all these people they build more
shows they do more and i'm like why
aren't we doing that well we're doing
that quite literally with the tales from
the inverted world with the vlog with
several other shows i work on a pop
culture show we're working on and then i
just look at the right and the moderates
and the independence and i'm like they
don't do this they don't even peter
thiel right he goes after a gawker he
complains about fake news he funds
rumble that's fantastic but where's his
effort joe rogan complains about cnn
lying joe's massively wealthy he could
take a million bucks and be like have at
it they just don't do it but you know
what whatever we'll do it and then we'll
see where everyone else ends up and and
now we'll go to super chats cause you
know rant over but i i do want to stress
again
any any alternative competition to
silicon valley and their censorship is a
good thing if at the end of the day the
battle we have is
locals is not going to ban you and
rumble won't ban you
hopefully that's enough to attract more
people and displace the sensorious
nature it's not because rumble can ban
you at any time i'm sure it says that in
their terms of service
they do they have community guidelines
trust no centralized service to maintain
your life for you that is your job
yeah
yeah i don't think people saw facebook
going where facebook went in the early
days people probably were just like oh
this is cool it's just like a simple
service and now it's like they track
everything about you they know when you
poop
they they they're building a metaverse
instagram my god
all right all right we'll go to super
chats if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe to channel and go
to timcast.com become a member because
we're gonna have a members only segment
coming up at around 11 or so p.m you
don't want to miss it and we'll talk a
bit about loudoun county and how awful
you know all that stuff is
all right we got hairball
i'm not religious but i'm praying kyle
gets a fair trial
i agree a fair trial
it doesn't have to be
one-sided i don't think what i want i
just want to be fair right
sounds good
all right scove says minnesota national
guard here phase one of mandatory vacs
has begun phase two will be the ucmj
portion but it's not finalized yet
currently 15 percent have refused in my
unit and will be flagged barring them
from re-enlisting they've already begun
ucmg ucmj paperwork wow
wow crazy
all right let's see fearless soldier
says it was awesome meeting all of you
at the event keep fighting the good
fight and keep it the momentum you guys
have a lot of people that care about you
thank you
all right
evil zombie hamster says tim you saying
you've been on sets last night reminded
me of a question i've had for a while
now did you do a small cameo in
detective pikachu just after 30 minutes
into the movie pushing bill nye off
screen it really looks like you the
answer is no i didn't
that's a weird question that's funny i
am however in two episodes of a thousand
ways to die oh that's right you didn't
die
no i was a skater guy
my friend was a production assistant and
their skater guy quit like didn't show
up so she called me and she was like
dude we need skater guy for these this
this episode can you come
and i was like i guess and she was like
we'll pay you 50 bucks and i was like oh
and it cost me 50 bucks to get there
because i'd take a cab because it was a
last minute thing so i break even
basically
and i got to be on this show it was on
your imdb skater guy i don't think so i
hope some puts it i don't know i was
accused because the show premiered after
occupy wall street i was accused of
trying to use occupy wall street fame to
get to become an actor or something and
then i had someone wrote an article
accusing me that saying that i moved to
los angeles to become an actor which is
like the most absurd lie ever because
i'm a skateboarder and i move to la
because the skateboarding is good and
mostly just because it's california you
know you made it when there's people
accusing you of being a crisis actor
yeah that's right
all right let's see we got what we
got what does this say
cynosexual says tell ian to do research
into chemical ice nucleation for weather
modification whoa okay wow
all right
cal miller says anyone want to bet that
the media is going to cover the written
house case and alec baldwin longer than
the fall of afghanistan oh you bet i
mean but let's let's be real the right
house trial is going to be for i think
two weeks i think so yeah wow okay i'm
gonna have two weeks every day of some
video just like with the chauvin trial i
think that that they got the catharsis
out with the chauvin trial i'm not
getting i'm not feeling that fervents
and bloodlust that was there
i don't know man they'll ratchet up when
it needs to be it is getting cold though
and people don't like riding in the
winter it's inconvenient it's really
funny that rioters are deeply influenced
by the weather if it rains it won't
write crime crime is influenced by the
weather right yeah uh but crime i get
right yeah someone's like i'm not gonna
go outside and rob somebody cause i'll
get wet whereas someone's like a black
man was murdered by the police yeah i
could protest injustice but it is pretty
cold out so i'll stay no it's it's when
it uh crime rises in the summer
systematically every single year and
nobody has a good explanation why
there's interesting research that looks
at um
fluctuations in prison violence in
relation to when the ac is working and
not that they've got data on
and and when the ac goes out there's
more prison violence so like a lot of it
just comes down to people are not happy
when it's hot out yeah um and and yeah i
think you know i mean i do think like a
lot of last year's writing just came
down to people had been stuck inside for
three months and this was a socially
approved way to go outside and you know
act out all of their pent up aggression
and there's like
i'm sure there's less of that now but
it's they they've had the catharsis once
yeah that's enough
paul thunkam says a prop gun is a fake
gun with no firing pin
and the trigger is just spring loaded to
act like a real gun they keep saying a
prop gun because they don't want you to
realize that alec baldwin pointed a real
gun with a real bullet at a woman and
killed her that he doesn't believe
people should have to defend themselves
that's right
the jaded kriegsman says on this day in
2001 the patriot act was signed eroding
our freedoms and emboldening federal
authoritarianism restore the tenth
restore our rights
interesting 10th amendment heck yes
simone 9937 says i just began listening
to a book on a kentucky county during
the first civil war i wish i could say i
had never heard the term insurrection
used that much
so we had shane cashman who's writing
for tales from the inverted world and i
have i am so excited
so the first arc i guess we're not
really doing seasons or whatever the
first season is basically a collection
of stories essays from him like you know
he met a guy and there's a cold case and
his experience as a kid because we kind
of wanted to like introduce him and like
what his his angle is because because
we're skeptical right
the next season
goes to the confederacy
he went down to georgia
he's got the story of sherman's march to
the sea and like the story of the people
who were there and how effect affected
their families ghost stories ufos murder
mysteries conspiracies
it's gonna be so red
yeah just introducing like
when you read history books about
sherman's march to the sea
i think you know based on what i was
hearing the people down there have a
very very
gruesome telling of what it was like
compared to the watered-down version of
scorched earth he burned the south to
the ground yeah it was effective
yeah
but that but like man
yeah he was telling me that people did
not like hearing the word sherman down
there
because it was like
he burned to the ground but you know
destroying people's homes civilians
non-combatants
there's a lot of really dark stuff there
man
that that was that wasn't the first
iteration of scorched earth was it
no
it was not i think scorched earth goes
way back to oh yeah yeah it's a tactic
to retreat you can burn behind you and
if if you think you can't defeat the
incoming enemy you can burn your
frontier and all the cities and lands
and retreat into your entertainment
starve them just like russia did yeah
germany ussr excuse me
um i don't know what this says but i'm
cia says hello luke i'm not polish but
war zhao walch what's your vote
what does that mean i i have no idea
what you just said i just tried to
scramble words together just like you
did wars zawo
walters
you you uh you should learn polish
he makes strong assumptions about what
there's consonants how those concepts
w-a-l-c-z
w-a-u-s i don't know luke can't do it
this way so luke doesn't speak polish oh
he no he can't like do the so luke can't
do the letters that way you have to see
them i'm good yeah i got to see that
yeah the same way
all right let's see
bill hughes says if rittenhouse loses
there will be riots if he wins there
will be riots uh-huh that's right and
matthew day oliveira just says why not
but i don't know that's a reference to
so but thank you
tommy says you can tell people that know
nothing about guns defending out that
you can tell that it's people who know
nothing about guns defending alec the
first thing told uh told in our ltc
class is that you're responsible for
everything that comes out of the end of
a firearm you're holding of course yup
yeah
it's amazing though that the people who
uh uh want crazy gun control don't
believe in responsibility like allergies
well they're related right it's it's
that you can't imagine owning a
a a firearm is a scary thing it's like
you know you hold a gun for the first
time you're like wow i could kill
somebody with this and if you're the
sort of person who sees that and is like
well nobody i i understand the impulse
to say nobody should have that i think
it's wrong i think i think it's you know
ultimately a feudal impulse in america
but i understand that impulse in terms
of just like that that sort of passivity
i never thought when i got into a car
man i could kill somebody with this
i think that all the time getting into a
car the gun is like
very very easy to create a lot of damage
and like a six year old can do it which
is why it's different than most weapons
pretty much every other weapon
i feel like cars can do more damage than
a lot of guns but you need to you need
to be big and have gas in the tank and
have a key right there there are about
as many automotive particular vehicular
deaths in the united states per year as
uh gun homicides and gun suicides bars
are dangerous cars are really dangerous
yeah they're big
lydia just sent me it means varshava
valce which means warsaw's fights fight
there you go
probably you're starting the warsaw
uprising uh fighting against of course
the the nazis right on william gabriel
says what sword is on the wall behind
tim uh i got this from a mall it's a
mall sword oh cool
and it says something like seven souls
sword or something like that i don't
know what it is
it's just it's like a prop like it's
it's just a sword from a ball mythical
that's the mall
and we also have you can't see us off
camera we have the master sword hung up
as well also not a real sword it's uh
it's from the legend of zelda and we
were thinking about getting a wet stone
and actually making we'd have to we'd
have to redo the hill it's plastic and
make like a real
i'm pretty sure someone's probably
already done that i'm old-fashioned i
just have machetes there you go yeah i
got that luke's gotta go bushwhacking
yes clearing the brush to go down the
path into the forest
all right let's see we got
oh let's see
jaggertree says misfire like a hang fire
is what a bullet does not a gun which
means it didn't burn the powder properly
guns can malfunction abey's gun worked
fine baldwin's that's right he pulled
the trigger and a bullet came out oh
that so he's saying that a gun cannot
misfire the bullet misfires
people were saying that the crew was
were shooting at beer cans the guns yeah
and they had live bullets just mixed in
with all the blanks
oh alec baldwin's running the show isn't
he he was one of the executive producers
i think all right poor randall says
blaming policing as an institution is
like blaming guns for violence police
are but a tool it can be wielded for
good or bad and in most cases the police
are used for good the problem lies in
the culture i agree with that yes
andrew sutton says someone should buy a
racehorse and call it brandon i get the
feeling that people would cheer for it
you've got to call it let's go brandon
yeah
lee fagan says we need not worry when
kamala becomes president when she does
if she follows down the same route of
unconstitutional edict we will impeach
her too
well there you go
normies get out says please don't forget
that black rifle coffee bent the knee
and refused to stand with kyle
rittenhouse when he was photographed
wearing their t-shirt
i don't know the full details about it
but what i was told was don't believe
the new york times when they smear black
rifle coffee because the new york times
is fake news i don't know the full
details though so i don't really know
what to say
all right
caleb south says my eight-year-old
daughter was listening to the news with
me and when she heard about the fouchy
puppy torture she said so he's corona
deville
that's good if you haven't seen freedom
tunes newest short it's only 18 seconds
long but uh i once again provided the
voice of dr fauci and you should check
it out on freedom tunes on youtube
because it's really funny it's very
short but it's funny
all right let's see
jesus trisp says a bit of topic but is
it possible biden was trying to go super
saiyan during the town hall someone
please make this meme if it hasn't been
done yet yeah when biden was doing the
cornholio thing i'm sure he was because
goku you know he goes ah then his hair
spikes and turns gold and someone should
make the super saiyan meme of joe biden
sure
i would like to see it but um i'm pretty
sure he just has dementia and that's
what the fist clenching was because you
know he has dementia i think alec
baldwin was not an executive producer
he's just a regular producer but it's
kind of vague what that means so uh it
is vague executive producer usually is
just like you're a financier or you're
spearheading the project in terms of
like
you have a bunch of money and you're
like hey i want to do this hey guys make
a movie and a little bit cool and then
i'll come and check it later producers
are substantially more active
so when i was working on documentaries
and stuff like that in shorts the
executive producers were like
the executive executives at the company
who would screen it after was done and
say yeah it's pretty good okay we'll
roll with it and the producers are the
ones who were on set all the time
instructing the staff the producers were
in charge of the entire production when
i was working when i was producing like
uh
the documentaries so like when there was
a producer and i was just hosting they
would be telling me what to do if i was
producing and hosting i'd be telling the
camera person what to do where to go
what to film and
so it that's why i think alec baldwin
was responsible
executive producers typically aren't
involved that much if at all so it's
just you know people get executive
producer credits all the time doesn't
mean much
yeah there were six producers underneath
the four executive producers on that
film baldwin was one of the six
producers
boris 89 says i'm an experienced
hollywood armorer so i can confidently
tell you that the lion's share of the
blame goes to the armor of that
lion share the blame goes to the armor
of that said way too much to explain in
a super chat message me and i'll explain
why i love the show it goes to the armor
where you're saying of the set that's
wrong wrong wrong wrong hollywood is
full of a bunch of psychotic individuals
who are saying the responsibility isn't
the person who's wielding a gun and
pulling the trigger it's all three when
i hand someone an airsoft rifle i do the
exact same things i don't care it's got
an orange tip on it i'll pull out the
magazine i'll pull the hammer back and
say this is airsoft look and i'll show
them that it's not a real gun i'll show
them the cartridge and i'll say here's
the airsoft there is airsoft there there
are pellets in this we only use
biodegradable stuff by the way one of
the plastic guards good i'm happy and
that's just airsoft
because people
i
i don't care if we have replicas you're
treated the exact same way this is what
people need to understand
if you're holding something that looks
like a gun
and you treat it like it's no it's no
big deal it's not loaded and you raise
it up and point it at someone guess what
they will shoot you
so maybe in hollywood they're like
i i got to tell you i cannot imagine
being on a hollywood set where someone
thinks they can draw a replica gun on
someone else with no consequences that
is insane
the two people he he shot her and and
the director the ball went through her
yeah have you seen the video of the guy
in the shooting range and he's with his
friends and then he has the gun and he
loads it then he points it at his friend
and the instructor just grabs his arm
puts him in a lock and pins him down
good yep i saw that yeah
or when will smith smacks the gun down
that's what should be done
yep
this idea that you can wield a a live
firearm with no responsibility is fake
news and if you work in hollywood and
you believe that
don't be surprised when alec baldwin
kills another person because if this guy
goes on to work in in hollywood where
he's like no no everybody it's fine it
was the armorer's fault let's get a new
armorer and the policy stands
no i tell you this they're going to be
like oh maybe we shouldn't do this maybe
we shouldn't point weapons at each other
and maybe we should manually check
the armorer's fault dude
tell that to a judge your honor the
weapon was handed me i was told that it
was it was not an active weapon and then
i was told to point it at the camera and
pull the trigger because i was supposed
to
yeah okay
all right tony gillard says yugioh
tournaments after a year or a year or so
of being canceled are finally coming
back and of course there's vaccine
mandates and mass mandates
well you can always not play yugioh find
a different hobby play magic the
gathering which is still not better
probably not better as a brief aside i
noticed a walmart did go public in 1970
that came up earlier do people still
play yukio oh yeah yeah it's big
okay yeah i never played it did you play
it when i was like 10 did you play magic
no
well might just way better anyway
yu-gi-oh is a manga about magic the
gathering basically because magic the
gathering was the first card game
and so they're basically playing some
version of it and then they made it my
favorite thing about yu-gi-oh is that
the show makes no sense like there's no
rules to the card game it's just like
yu-gi-oh is like i'll play blue eyes
white dragon and you're like uh
there's like you can literally just do
whatever you want the game makes no
sense sounds interesting but they
eventually made rules and changed them
and then like made a real game
all right wrath of paul says project
veritas has a video of new jersey's
new jersey governor consultant saying he
will implement vaccine mandates after he
wins the election of course he knows
it's wildly unpopular and is planning on
doing it anyway new jersey friends vote
him out yeah
i would say vote him out but if if i
actually thought it was possible i think
they'll blindly just vote him in and be
like yay and then what happens i'll go
oh no why is my life getting worse
nope
leave all right ignis hydra says hey tim
any new shirts coming to the shop or is
there too much competition in the room
um you know we do need to get on some
shirts we need to make something i don't
think so i know you guys are good you
guys i think your store is pretty great
we'll make competing t-shirts and then
you know ian can wear the the tim caster
version yeah i want i want i want this
to be dealt with within a physical fight
fashion
i think that's the diploma you know we
should deal with this problem i think
we'll start making like cheap knockoff
versions of luke's shirts yes like i
tested positive for freedom will be like
i took a test and it said i liked
freedom
it doesn't make sense but you like you
know ripping them off you could have the
domain the second best political website
since of course my website is
thebestpoliticoshirts.com
i actually think we'll buy that one the
second best political shirts
someone's buying it i've given you too
many good ideas damn it i want to i want
a commission on that one we'll make the
even better
political shirts or how about we make
like better than luke's yes better than
luke's t-shirts
yeah
all right let's see andrew biko says the
term film shot comes from chrono
photographic gun invented by james mary
in 1882 please look it up interesting
andre magruder if the republicans win
the house in the midterms a republican
replaces nancy get rid of the vp we get
a republican president hmm interesting
impeach them you mean
all right dozerman says i'd like to see
this guy try this his bs with michael
malus i love luke but i feel michael
would light this guy up i mean he's
talking about you okay
okay i'm not trying to light anyone up i
think it's important to have different
voices and different opinions and i
think it's important to have these
conversations so i'm having to talk to
michael mathis
but it's good to have these
conversations and i'm not seeing this as
a combative thing i'm seeing this more
of a of an exchange of ideas and i've
been dying to talk about the
deindustrialization with the rise of
globalization and the rigged war on
drugs being responsible for the rise of
rise of crime in the 1970s but that's
another issue
i'd like to talk about
being involved in the drug epidemic
on the after show maybe if that comes up
yeah dude
our guest is just shaking his head
the chrono photographic guns are awesome
this was 1882. it was it looks like a
rifle and it was the predecessor of the
camera the movie camera cool we got a
super chat from a
viva
frettie vibe
yeah v viva fray
do we know do we know that i don't know
that doesn't come she's french viva he
says i'm obviously partial to rumble and
locals but building your own dev are you
still dependent on aws and the like
peace and again nice meeting you we'll
do it again yes uh you can use whatever
hosting service you want you can make
your own server if you want that might
be too complicated for people and we
certainly can set up some you know
hosting uh services
it can be expensive but i'll put it this
way
there is a reason why these platforms
charge a percentage
they're making money off you now that's
fine they've done the work and they're
cutting a profit
i just think that if we can create a
simple program for free
and then you take on the personal
responsibility of maintaining your
subscriber data it can never be sold to
outside corporations people's privacy
will always be protected from google or
any other company that might want to buy
or infiltrate or you know whatever
and you'll save a lot of money i will
say this
the percentage you give up to these
companies
is insane compared to the actual cost
it's a it's like an order of magnitude
more
but i i think it would probably only
cost for us like
one to two percent
you know to like maintain the system
right now we're using rumble for
members stuff yeah what's the what would
the cost of that be if we were hosting
it locally
uh if we hosted our own videos
way more that's the challenge is someone
can pay ten dollars a month and then
watch one video a thousand times and
cause a thousand times the cost to your
server so you could build something in
where like you get to watch it once no
it's a subscription i'm not worried
about that it's it's like an equation
the more content we're producing on
members only the more money we lose
right so we we have some tales from the
inverted world members only
conversations you were hanging out with
shane right yeah we did a show on monday
so if if someone pays 10 bucks and they
get one video per you know monday
through thursday and then we add friday
which we did and now we're gonna add
sunday nights that means we're spending
more money but we're getting the same
amount from the individual because we're
increasing the value you know percentage
for the user
that's good but it's also why you'll see
netflix or hulu be like we're raising
the cost because we have too much
content and people are watching way more
and so now we can't afford to cover the
cost of bandwidth but
either way i think that's that's less
relevant to the fact that
10 of the amount of money you make as a
creator is way too much
way too much to it's an insane profit
let's put it this way go to graphtreon
look at like um you want to go to
graphing right now
graphtreon.com go and look up the top
creators and and tell me who's the top
creator
oh how do you spell graphtran with an
app graph and then t r e o n
p h yeah graph graph
graph tree on
i want to tell a story while i'm doing
this coming up alone you can't type in a
word so once upon a time ian couldn't
true crime obsessed is number one then
we have chapel trap how many how many
how many forty six thousand seven
hundred how much money they make that if
it ten dollars a month minimum that's
four hundred and sixty seven thousand
dollars a month oh it doesn't have one
okay so so number two chapeau trap house
thirty six 36 734 patrons 162 000 a
month it does not cost 16 000. is it 162
you said yeah it doesn't cost 16 000 per
month
to run a member service they are giving
away
16 000 per month for no reason for a
one-time cost of a grand you can have
someone build out exactly what they get
from patreon yeah especially if you're
hosting your stuff on on rumble
you don't have to host your own data
that's the point it costs money to have
private uh um private uh uh bandwidth
yeah like if so when we we have rumble
we gotta pay a lot of money for that it
is expensive it is very expensive it is
substantially less expensive than giving
away 10 percent
that's mind-blowing that chapo is giving
away 16 000
per month
you could hire a web dev
on a six figure salary
to work for you year round to develop
and maintain the site for you and its
wordpress and plugins
and you could pay less you could you
could hire a dev at eight grand a month
and cut your cost in half
i just don't understand it but i guess
people with they don't know they don't
they don't know
so hopefully we can change all that
right oh yeah
all right let's see
brian knoll says ian watch dave rubin's
episode that aired today he publicly
explains all of the terms and conditions
of the acquisition he didn't get a
payout interesting so you got it you
gotta you gotta you gotta you gotta
relax see
i do have to relax so he sold the
company but he didn't get a payout is
that what i was just told
yeah that's what they're saying yeah
okay i'll find out i'll look for eric
uh thibadu
says yo ian bro chill out dave is still
invested in locals and the co-founder is
still the ceo of locals you don't know
what you're talking about bro looking
look into it
so what what does that mean does that
mean that um
does that mean that rumble bought a
portion of dave's equity or
i mean an acquisition requires some
exchange maybe it maybe dave got a got a
got stock in rumble or something or like
private equity and rumble or something
like that in exchange for it
yeah i gotta look into this more
yeah my approach to the whole thing the
whole time was
create decentralized tech so you can
never be banned again
i don't see rumble and patreon as
solving that problem ultimately
i still think it's good what they're
doing but i don't see it solving the
problem
not in the long run in the long run it's
going to be this you want to follow me i
say follow me at you know tim at
timserver.com
and then
i own the server no one can ban me when
you open your website and look at your
feed you'll see tweets from me kind of
like rss
and no one can ban me ever
someone can say i don't want to see him
and block me from their website but can
never ban me can ever take away my
revenue my subscribers you are
invincible
all right we'll do one more super chat
here we got chad michael taylor says tim
i am the manager of a comic and game
store mtg warhammer warhammer etc we are
fighting the culture war here just
started vlogging from the shop cool glad
to hear it i think we're going to be
opening a game shop on fridamastan yes
we got to build a big building and the
problem is steel costs are through the
roof so it's very expensive and we're
having a hard time because these
companies are just i call a company i'm
like i need to still steal building and
they're like okay we'll call you back
and i'm like and then and then they call
me back and they waste my time and they
ask me a bunch of questions i'm like guy
i need you know we're looking at like 75
by like 100 or something and i'm like we
got a lot of work to do before winter
can you do it they're like well let me
call you back and i'm like click dude
it's frustrating probably just need to
hire a project manager to run the whole
thing
matt lucas says dave got stock is a
salaried employee his bro in-law is ceo
interesting well we'll see how it plays
out i think it's a good thing but uh
we'll we'll wrap it up there if you
haven't already smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends go to timcast.com
become a member of members only segment
coming up soon you can follow the show
at tim cast irl you can follow me
personally everywhere at tim cast
charles you want to shout anything out
yeah sure uh thanks for having me on the
show you can follow me on twitter i'm at
charles f lehman
uh
yeah it's a good time cool right on man
and uh thanks for having me and
seriously thank you for sending me this
important reminder of my people's
history this was first used as a symbol
for polish resistance and the
underground movement during world war ii
the communists when they took over ger
when they took over poland after world
war ii they made this illegal that's why
it was a sign of resistance under the
solidarity movement so uh sincerely
appreciate it and uh if you guys want to
send us stuff make sure to address it to
us
and the address is on timecast.com and
this also reminds me that not all hope
is lost no matter what the odds you
could always fight for what is right and
that was also the theme of the video
that i made on
lookuncensored.com today as well hope to
see some of you guys there
yeah one of your one of your commenters
uh is saying that i am trash or a trash
can emoji but on the other hand another
of your commentaries said that i look
like a 60s gi joe action figure and that
was awesome so i'm considering this
i'll i'll i'm going to we'll tell you
the latter yeah yeah
i love it thanks for coming guys this is
fantastic you can follow me in
crossland.net happy to be here see you
later you guys may follow me on twitter
at sourpatchlitz we will see all of you
over at timcast.com for that member
segment thanks for hanging out bye guys
you